[Music]
hello and welcome back to our 2013 u.s.
test championship coverage we were just
getting into this fascinating struggle
between Tata barber ha Mian and Irina's
on nuke in the dragon and what do you
think gasps I don't know boy I tell you
this move Queen aged 2 Knight takes b2
is a wild variation there's also a
knight a3 check both are scary another
defensive resource actually for black
that I got fascinated with on our break
was that after Bishop g4 I'm trying as
black trying to prevent white from
playing age 5 and trying to pick up a
tempo against this rook on d3
fascinating just really nice sharp
business going on here I'm still
confused frankly as to what the outcome
verdict should be in this game well a
real treat for us and the viewer is we
are going to keep a close eye on this
game and a grandmaster Ashley has some
more on it we commentators live for
right it's a dragon people are trying to
kill each other attacks on both sides
it's incredible and I was looking at
this of course very intently with the
computer to see what it thought about
this position and there's some crazy
stuff in here first of all 94 it gives
us best and this line Queen 2h 2 is
actually quite fascinating if Knight
takes on b2 the move
h5 is playable and if you play rook c3
hoping to hoping to block on h3 the
Queen can go up to h4 according to
computer keeping the Queen in the lead
and this gives white a decisive
advantage the attack is big it's already
up to two point eight six and it looks
as though black really has no defense
against what's going to happen now
because you won't be able to interpose
and stop the Queen from doing its due in
this position as the H file is going to
open up you see this capture will happen
at some point and the attack is coming
straight down the H line and is
very difficult especially since this
pawn is pinned to the king because of
this bishop so this line is apparently
quite good for white going back just a
little bit the move you suggested yes
Bishop to g4 seems to be the best
defense according to the computer
although it still thinks that h5 will
come in at some point so crazy position
totally wild
nobody's understanding this without deep
analysis even the computer disagrees
with itself depending on how many
seconds you give it to think so it's
going to be completely difficult
extremely difficult for the players to
figure this out one thing I might add is
this move g4 way back when this pawn
move pawn up to g4 this move is known as
a very imbalancing move in a position
back in the classical days this move
just often wasn't played people stayed
much more in the center and when you
played this move g4 s because you had a
direct mating attack we're seeing this
move or we've seen this move actually
now in the last 20 years we played in
almost any opening for almost any reason
you know chess is about control in the
center but g4 it is often played to
maybe kick a night off of f6 which is
controlling in the center so you're
indirectly controlling the center we've
seen this move in a lot of games in the
game between Feingold and Nour wits this
move was played very early on I believe
yeah right here and move 10 the move g4
kicking a bishop away was played in
another game we see this same rule was
played I believe was yes in this game
Robson versus mark Arnold again as early
as moved 12 more typical we see this in
the Sicilian this move g4 get played but
the caveman game for me is this between
Benjamin and a Cobian a very important
game for the standings look at this this
G form will played in this position very
early I mean very calm natural looking
position and Joe played the move g4
generating a natural response he 5 and
after C takes he takes he just marched
right ahead with g5 and now the movie 4
has been played attacking his knight
this is the some serious caveman
of whites King still in the middle of
the board where where's its home even I
mean Joel is decided his King doesn't
need a home is fine where it is so we're
seeing some totally unbalanced crazy
wild wild games this round continuing
the theme we saw yesterday back to you
in the studio
fantastic games today I'm really excited
I mean nothing can beat with this have
ironies any again but you know at some
point it's going to clarify and the rest
of the games are gonna blow up right
exactly well just what Maurice is saying
g4 has become a popular move in so many
variations and in that last game that
Maurice was showing it was a great idea
the Armenian player Levon Aronian I was
in China in Ningbo playing in the World
Team Championships for the US team when
I think it was against Hari Krishna that
lavona uncork g4 and one of beautiful
model games against a couple as we would
call sam sevilla honest guy there yeah i
was throwing some patties that was one
of your that was a fantastic result you
beat a couple super grandmasters right
including Judith Polgara on her birthday
I felt so bad about it
Hayes we have to remember to mention
Kaden 12th is turning 15 today think he
is the birthday boy and we'll probably
take a quick look at his game later and
I think in one of the breaks we also
have his James Bond impression he
actually just starred in a music video
no way which it was a TLC trio that's a
group out of out of Utah where McCadden
lives and they were doing a cover of
Skyfall by Adele it's very cool it's
nice to see I'm Katie you know working
so hard on the game and also working so
hard to promote jazz yeah exactly what
we need and now is the time wonderful
I just have one story I think sure
you're gonna love this one about Judith
Bogart so as ending both China
I've played thousands of tournament
games and I'm sure that it's happened to
me in the past that I've played somebody
on his or her birthday but I can't
recall ever having that
situation before the round would you to
the arbiter before starting the clock
said welcome everybody and let's
congratulate Judith on her birthday so
there was a big applause for Judith as
the game was about to game begin and
Judith said to me please Yassir you can
make a present you can remove anything
you want from the board mm-hmm so I was
thinking well remember the great Bobby
Fischer said that he could give night
odds to any lady in the world until he
was challenged on it of course the
Soviets challenged lemon he backed down
from the challenge but because women
have made such great strides in the
world of chess I reached across the
board and lifted her knight from no no
no you're not a gentleman I meant you
have to give me a present and so only
very very reluctantly did I give her
back her Knight oh very nice well there
is sometimes a birthday curse grand
master Joel Benjamin did beat me on my
birthday and that was a December 31st
usually there's not a lot of chess
tournaments held that day but this was
like some bizarre party slash chess
tournament with like electronic music
and all sorts of Burning Man art it was
a it was an experience we were part of
an art installation but it was also a
real game at the same time something
that the folks over at the World Chess
Hall of Fame would undoubtedly enjoy
you're always doing something very
interesting Jennifer you lead an
adventuresome life well and what do we
have in a thought to have that if you
have any news let's because every move
is critical in that gap what do we have
I haven't we
it's bell game right in the bottom at
the very bottom okay she captured on g5
in this extraordinary sharp sword
instead of moving the Knight to c4 which
is what we expected she switched it up
and actually took the bishop on g5 which
leaves her h-file totally open after h
takes d5 absolutely so the Queen is
ready to come dates true the only nice
thing is that if you move your work to
88 for
since the bishop one g7 does guard
against mate but with that Bishop one d5
and the pawns pushing forward this looks
like it could be really problematic for
black wears not gonna play now let's
take let's just play out a line like say
black now please Knight c4 or what
happened then okay well you you pay yeah
okay so you must play rook e8 it appears
let's go in and pay a visit Jack and now
we can maybe play okay you're just gonna
take on our seven huh I'm threatening
threatening checkmate on the spot okay
so taking on f7 totally for us this is
nice to analyze when everything is
totally for us precisely even though
it's it can be difficult because the
vision it's also easy because you don't
have to look at the different branches
right right so what sometimes people
don't understand about great calculators
is what they're good at is really more
horizontal thinking than vertical
thinking they're thinking about all the
possibilities and the branches sometimes
it's a long type of variation can be
easier but especially when it's so
forcing as we see right now that's yeah
that's what I mean when it's forcing
there aren't many branches well this
looks actually completely decisive by
the way so what's your your thread is
pawn takes g6 followed by rock f1
precisely just sacrifice your bishop on
f6 basically and then there would be
that amazing work yeah show us a mate
just for fun oh yeah let's say I don't
know we're gonna throw with this rook
over here perhaps okay okay then we have
something like Czech and in case the
king is forced to drop back we have a
check and now say you play say you play
King year instead gotta beat some wow
grab oh you can also take an 88 yeah
that's even prettier much prettier you
are absolutely on the button correct
jack and mate does it and the computer
says here hashtag won speaking of
hashtags us chess champs if you've got
some tweets for us we have some prizes
to give away and of course the original
hashtag was a moniker for it's a
shortcut for checkmate right but I'm now
it's better known for
it's used on Twitter exactly
popularization of chess right right I'm
just thinking that this move Knight
takes g5 in a situation that we seem
where every move is absolutely critical
this move I think has just actually cost
black the game because after H takes g5
this threat of coming over to h2 and
checkmating on the H file really whites
attack plays itself there is nothing
exactly 2ez 2ez maybe I'm not I'm not a
big fan of this move the only reason to
play Knight g4 is to stop Queen h2 but
this night on g4 is no longer
participating in attack against White's
King so it becomes yeah it becomes a
play on one goal I think after this
night goes to g4 what if we try to go
really fast and just play like Queen g2
how does that work out for us or Queenie
one maybe Queenie one this and just
woman rather oh okay well Queen h4 is
the big threat let's see what I can do
to prepare myself so I'll make lifts
from my King off you'll come to h4
probably anyway sure that's a plan okay
and then I guess in order to to save
yourself you'll have to play something
like e six so that after after King f8 r
f5 move doesn't just just crush like it
did before exactly so I don't know if I
should toss in a rook c3 anywhere but
let's just go with a six so we can see
what a variation might look like should
we go in with a check I think so because
taking on g4 allows black to take back
on d5 right so that night then I might
be hanging but after taking taking on d5
I think we have lost more than we have
gained right that trade probably
appeases black getting rid of that
Bishop on defy for that night on g4 has
to be in the favor of the second
clarifying things in lines so that kind
of knows are at high
and so now after King to f8 our
candidate moves I mean black actually
might be like holding on here in a way
because the bishop on h8 stops against
the maids mm-hmm
f5 you you're pointing out just f5 looks
dangerous though we should try a 5 right
just to blast it blacks King we seen
this before trying to open the F file is
also scary exactly yeah sex act mate the
old Bobby line well I don't know I think
that Knight g4 probably is a required
move but boy it sure is looking bad in
my opinion for black in this game and
from a practical point of view very
difficult for black to play because now
she's not attacking and she's got a look
at a hundred different ideas by octave
and it's it's gonna be very difficult
for her to defend this now shall we we
look at another game just before we
leave one other point that the computer
makes and it's a very obvious point I
should have made it myself
earlier f4 f5 in preparation for
swinging the Queen over to the H file is
also exceedingly strong because you're
setting up threats like f5 takes g6 and
just blowing up the bunker on the Kings
side over here so f4 f5 looks also a
decisive attacking move for white Wow
just a fantastic position for white and
just much easier to play so tight I'll
bring home Ian with two and a half
points looking to add another win to her
record and perhaps challenge the
front-runner Irina crash exactly
speaking of attacking the frontrunners
we haven't seen it for a while Larry
Kristensen
I actually liked his game very much
there was a in against John Bryant and
this very standard opening for black
John made a very provocative move with
his knight c6 I think most players would
simply have castled at that precise
moment get
the key tucking the king away but knight
c6 provoked Larry and you don't need
much to provoke Larry Larry took
advantage of the moment play d5
attacking the knight after the trade of
pawns Queen e7 check Bishop e2 95
castles by Larry castles d5 d6 was
played but you want me to play d4 in the
first move right oh my gosh look at that
pass pawn go Queen f6 Knight takes e5
Queen takes e4 what yeah so fortunately
d7 fortunately for black d7 doesn't
quite work not because of reworked the
eight which would allow captures
captures making a queen and you're
unable to recapture 92 right because of
the pin right so instead of that though
black has much better reply after d7 you
can simply take the pawn on d7 take the
offend there and after Queen d7 the
bishop won't need to hangs and this is
certainly not what Larry wants now
totally dry yes black has equalized so
we go back to the game and Myra didn't
play the move d7 instead played this
little move rook e1 anticipating that
he'll get a discovered attack reddening
d7 because now our work would be pretty
Bishop would be protected exactly so B
should be six and now three and have we
caught up with the players
I like White's position very much
because obviously I'm nibbling upon over
here and at the same time this pawn on
d6 is the most important pawn in the
position so Larry is a big favorite
right now in this game and very
meaningful for the leaders standings in
the leadership at the tournament so
tough defensive stat tasks here for John
Bryant and now we have Maurice Ashley
with the move of the round so far well
we're seeing some fighting games
everywhere even in openings where you
don't suspect that they would explode in
this position between Alex
and the Chuvalo of an alux onus Chuck
usually white Shabaab is the one who
likes to play these crazy lines and hero
district playing what looks like I saw
the line but they're about to explode
the move b5 was played defending this
pawn on c4 and after rook to d1 night to
b4 not even finishing his development is
yet in the move b3 was played and now
after captures you thought you'd expect
a normal movement instead the move d5
trying to crack open the center and
after captures the move e5 now down
three pawns is white trying to break
through in the center somehow and black
with all this chaos on the board a piece
under attack decides to do what simply
castle how you like them apples
total hole madness on the board right
now and of course the computers calmly
saying that it's dead equal zero point
zero zero yes I know you love these
computers and their evaluations eighth
no I don't mean yeah I know I mean
totally explosive position massive
imbalance pawns being sacrifices Maurice
mentioned and the computer just coming
to this conceptual idea that the
positions dead even it just makes me
shake my head and frustration like do I
understand chest me no I don't I mean
it's just too hard at times so amazingly
enough Shabalala three pawns down hasn't
captured the piece and it's dead calmly
plays this move a two a three that was a
last move that was played in this game
pardon me oops I've got to work on my
arrows threatening to capture this
Knight and one day certainly capturing
this Knight Wow it's just looks it's
it's wild I don't even know where to
begin trying to analyze these imbalance
positions it's just crazy crazy stuff
another imbalance position we have
Benjamin's game and we actually have yes
we have a question from one of our our
listener
here and viewers and I really cannot
even pronounce this Twitter handle so
day via cat all right well he asks um
why not gh in Benjamin's game 15 on the
15th move okay
we'll bring that game up and to our
screen again this idea in the last score
defense to the Queens gambit declined g4
as introduced by Levon Aronian and Nimbo
China has created this situation and
what move did he like sacrificing the
night on on f3 so sacrifices in the air
today taking just taking on h6 air right
in Maui taking on f3 right and I'm okay
so I assume the idea is something with
rook do you want or takes on g7 breaking
open the king position Queen f3 maybe to
start mm-hmm and then just it it looks
so in with the idea that for instance
like if you were to play Queen f3
right and then if black word not that
they should a bit if black were to take
on HX
okay and we were to play queen h5 or
what do you want check maybe to start g1
check I guess the king is gonna go to
the corner cage and if we go to h5 now
you've got although it seems like Queen
f6 defends matters doesn't not mm-hmm it
certainly does that yeah and I don't
know I don't think that uh
Joe really wants to could go for this
because you've got a couple pawns but
black has adequate resources it seems to
me he could like he could be playing for
rook g8 in order to just trade off this
very aggressive rook on g1
but go back for a second because the
sacrifice actually is very intriguing
what would have happened in this
position you leave this pawn hmm I'm
trying to I heard an eight an attack in
a different manner it's wrong to me
though it feels like the best that waits
getting out of this is some kind of perp
and
I think weight should do better than
that like even that position we were
just looking at with a queen coming to
Essex it seems like big white might in
the best case scenario be able to play
something like Bishop to g6 and then you
know we're playing Queen h6 and maybe
we'll get some kind of perk out of it
per I'm like Bishop let's say we play
Bishop T through here maybe like Bishop
d6 is an idea and Queen takes eight
sheiks and rook g6
cetera but it seems like the the best
will get there as a perpetual agreed and
I do think that row g8 probably is in
the favor of black not sacrificing the
piece which was Joel's decision sure
looks apropos to my eyes and yeah I like
you are threatening to come over here
Queen h5 and we might be able to drum up
a very serious attack in this case
without being a piece down right and you
got to be careful okay in some of those
variations maybe white could have bailed
out and played something like work take
c8 in Queens e4 check and it means you
want an exchange back right but I think
you got to be careful when you're trying
to arrange an attack and you only have
two minor pieces
mm-hm if you sacrifice one of them you
just may not have enough wood for the
fire piece I see he's actually right
well this still looks like a promising
position to my eyes for Joel
I wonder if Ramirez can really make this
challenge work I was just looking at a
line that goes like this this I don't
know about rook h5 but the idea at least
from blacks point of view is to come
down here pinning the bishop to the king
if you take the pond which everybody
would like Knight f6 and maybe it's
black on the counter-attack that might
carry the day for him of energy in
today's games and we have a Grandmaster
Ashley with another crazy Jeep on
maneuver
in the cat's abuyin sky key game Jen
this some kind of Jeep on disease going
on going around I don't know everybody's
catching the bug because the Jeep on is
becoming the start of the day
this one though looks extraordinarily
dubious you look at this position here
you see a very natural position for
black everything looks normal it looks
like you might think about castling
actually even more spectacular move was
the move Knight to c5 because if this
pawn takes this knight than Queen takes
on d3 and the night to see if I would
have been a very strong move in the
computer approves of this move for black
as blacks best option at the moment 95
would have been a great move instead the
young Elena Katz now residing in
Brighton Beach Brooklyn when Brooklyn
honor and played g5 and unfortunately
this one just looks bad I mean this King
does not have a stable home anymore and
this G pawn I'm not even sure what
exactly it's doing I know these G pawn
moves have become much more popular much
more fashionable fashionable but in this
circumstance it looks like it's just
should have stayed back home the Jeep on
has gone viral that's what it seems like
today's round isn't it oh yeah workable
a lot of these Jeep on openings it seems
like it comes up in so many different
constellations and like the four
openings of course and sicilians and it
is definitely catching on more and more
but a lot of the time it's just weakened
yeah well thank goodness because the
classical school of chess is keep your
flank pawns especially those in front of
your King at home so your king we means
there's a good example for instance to
play g5 in this position if it were
black smooth that would have very few
positives and a lot of negatives so this
is kind of like that's why we like get
so excited when people play g4 because
it's really the exception yes yes and it
draws our attention I'm fascinated by
the game between the two Alexes
as white only shook our third seed as
black I was just looking at a variation
that would go knight c6 captures on f6
Bishop takes f6 and now rook takes d5
winning upon and from White's point of
view if you can just get the moves
Bishop b2 and rook over and he'd have an
excellent excellent game maybe even
close to winning I've been looking at
the move Queen ee8 for just a moment
with this Bishop firing down against
this knight on c3 it's hard to say well
it's been hard to say since the start of
this game what's going on and I still
find myself utterly flummoxed confused
Oh after after for example Queen takes a
e8 rook takes e8 rook c5 defending the
knight trying to attack the knight these
natural moves which I've displayed on
the board the computer starts to favor
black just by playing natural moves so
Shabalala is gonna have to come up with
something very extra special to win very
strange position indeed yeah
odd type of positional compensation you
know we're used to like these
slash-and-burn sacrifices which lead to
a concrete line and here it's a little
bit more more permanent yeah well here
we go I mean modern chess today has
become all about the initiative who has
the initiative and how to make it a
purposeful one and turning it into a
material advantage very sharp crazy
games exactly some of the principles of
before no double pawns you know capture
towards the center it's funny how often
grandmasters ignore these rules in order
to get piece activity and dynamism which
tends to be the ruling principles these
days and now we've got our game
Christensen and Bryan in which Larry has
a very big advantage you know getting
his pawn to d6 you know this is the kind
of thing where we would sacrifice a pawn
to get this beautiful pawn on d6 and
then things might be equal right
theoretically but the fact that we have
it and we sacrifice nothing it's got to
be great for away exactly well this
fortunately is the kind of calm chess I
truly can appreciate being upon ahead
and having this massive passed pawn on
d6 blast move by larry was rook takes b7
winning upon bringing rook to the
seventh which we all aspire with our
rooks and also going after this third
after another pawn the a 7-pound rook c3
was played Larry Christensen really in
the driver's seat in this game he only
has to look out for one cheap boat type
of tactic where maybe his King is a bit
expose this move rook c3 Telegraph's the
intention of black to sacrifice the
exchange I mean even that probably does
anything after rook to e3 oh you do have
your Bishop one b3 sorry so yeah that's
true we have two after-work f3 takes on
f3 Queen at Queen I don't believe this
is gonna work we could proudly play
Queen III or we three just something
that gets to the d3 square right you
stop all the attack and then we're just
hoping to exchange an upon I don't get
it I don't think you can really play
work f3 in too many variations mm-hmm
but maybe you're right just like the the
hidden possibility of it gives black
some counter play right yeah I don't
think so I mean this just looks really
bad this bad did you have to give up
that pawn on b7 I think I did you know
way to defend it basically huh well
essentially after the move rook b1 if
you don't let the rook come down here on
the b7 square then the bishop is simply
going to come down to on the b7 square I
mean John Bryan could have played a b8
but I'm thinking either rook takes or
Bishop takes why it's going to be a
whole pawn up with no compensation
I can see none visible to my eyes like
compensation I would think yeah as we
call it but we've got another crazy Jeep
on push in the Women's Championship I
don't get it
I don't get it they must all have gotten
the memo now we know Rex Sinquefield
who's the sponsor of the the tournament
in the club who has done quite a bit to
change the world of chess
he's now actually in the loop of the
Missouri Sports Hall of Fame for his
generosity in the field of chess
he loves the move G for Jen I know you
you coach him and you try to get him not
to play g4 but he's gonna get you today
because everybody's playing g4 look at
this position here it looks like a very
composition between me and zoton ski
suit on ski having lost yesterday
probably trying to get back in the swing
of things and the natural move to my
eyes is a move like Queen to d3 very
normal setting up this nice attack on
this diagonal here maybe some days you
know get a mating attack going now
Victoria decides it's time to play g4 it
is it never a time to play g4 yes what
is going on Oh what can I say Murray's
g4 that's that's what's happening well
White Castle so I guess that means it's
a good idea to play g4 but don't worry
about Rex I've got somebody blindfolding
him at any moment that the G pawn is
pressed he won't be personally affected
by it by these these crazy ladies and we
haven't looked at the ball beyond for
the ladies and some time let me just
bring up the game the Peter crush as
white against Angelina bellows kaya and
Angelina by the way has two points out
of out of three so she's going quite
well herself after not playing many US
Women's Championship and didn't she lose
the first game and now has one two on
the trunk that's right so she lost one
of the strongest players in the field
right and we have this after d7 d 6 this
is this formation became known as the
BOD Vinik triangle
position and while black has given her
opponent a fantastic outpost on d5 the
pawns on c5 and E 5 control a lot of
squares
Angelina didn't play I didn't follow up
with the normal d76 instead played as me
well what appears to me a very hyper
aggressive f7 f5 I don't approve
normally with black you tried to play
solid out of the opening but ok she she
has something very concrete in mind kg
move Bishop e7 we'll have to ask
Angelina
thoughts behind that Bishop g2 Knight f6
castles castles a2 a3 arena borrowing a
page from my own junior days where I
enjoyed playing a three rupee one and B
for a great deal my dad has a famous
quote about that he liked to jokingly
say ya sir please III be for work he won
every game and they call him a genius I
shout out to Mike thanks for all your
support Mike a rugby one rook b8 now
that's a little bit of a surprise for me
rook b8 again I've been expecting
Angelina to play d7 d6 and bring her
Bishop out if possible yeah they're
practicing it making sure the 95 is into
Jersey My dear King h8 or with 8 6
covers and cons but how how does the
inclusion of rook b8 help that strategy
I'm I'm mystified okay rook b8 was
played Queen e8 well this this is
obvious obvious evil intentions of Queen
h5 and F 5 F 4 and Bishop h3 check and
mate Angelina is just bringing her Club
today yeah it's a reverse Grand Prix
type of setup with f5
okay well arena had seen enough jumped
into the outpost Knight d5 hoping to
reduce some of the firewood Bishop d6
very creative play by bellum house Gaia
but again such a classical player like
Irina
I don't know if she's gonna be phased
here yeah concerns here yeah this looks
like black is simply asking too much of
her position and this the inclusions of
these moves Bishop d6 and Roby 8 really
don't make a harmonious eeling let's put
it that way
e4 my goodness no I'm really I'm
confused I love this peon shadow bishop
on this diagonal so the movie for would
not have been attracted to me I would
have thought frankly about the move
Knight h4 going after this pawn on f5
and hoping to yeah
Queen h5 with III just putting an end to
any of those King side attack exactly
and your pieces are so awkwardly placed
for the endgame so Irina would be
certainly happy to get an endgame after
Queen h5 III oh yeah 9h 4 seems like a
pretty good try maybe Angelina would
have simply pushed the pawn to f4 upon
Knight age 4 Knight each for for very
reasonable move as you point out
something that Angelina wants to do
anyway but after e3 it seems to mean
like White's pieces are coming more and
more into play faster than blacks after
all that Bishop I see sure is not an
overwhelming anyone is it the lack of
harmony here is really notable like
we're playing with out our bishop on c8
which tends to be a really key attacker
in this line right because normally
we're trying to get a queen h5 Bishop
each 394th in blind here we've got our
Bishop doorman and the you know I would
even think like maybe Bishop b8 followed
by d6 but the rook sing away not that
that would have been good anyway that
just saying it's like it the work on b8
actually cuts off one of the bishops for
treating squares which could be annoying
in some variations well let's see what
arena had in mind she is the tournament
leader for good reason and I was 24 we
see this move b5 okay he's now
she's trying to solve the problem of her
two rotten pieces on b8 and CA so when
she plays b5 she opens up the rook and
the bishop right well imagine this one
how's this for a tricky idea how about
after E for white says listen I think
I'm doing great with your Bishop on c8
how about a move like Knight g5 inviting
black to accept a gambit pawn queen is
attacking over here notice that this
Bishop on d6 by the way has no defenders
this might just be very good and now it
takes f6 huge threat no time to play
Knight takes d5 because it's checkmate
on the spot let's show them that I'm
trying to get as many checkmates as
possible you're doing pretty good over
the course of these four days you've
gotten new many different styles of
checkmate sometimes falling into them
usually trying to create the hump here
of course the knight protects the Queen
as well as preventing the king's escape
by covering the square f7 so we go back
Angelina didn't didn't capture on e4 and
perhaps Knight g5 is what dissuaded her
b5 was played now Knight takes f6 oh my
goodness
okay still having Oh finally I
understand capturing on f5 keeping that
diagonal open for the bishop and maybe
one time at some future point using the
e4 square as an outpost I must say I
much prefer White's position at this
exact moment and arena to play again I
find myself drawn to this move Knight g5
simply so I can open up the bishop to go
to d5 I can also bring my bishop to the
e4 square attacking the rook and going
after the pawn on h7 I really like this
for white just everything about it it's
much much more harmonious for the first
player than the second I agree and I
think Irina excels in these types
and you know maybe her opponents are
trying to catch her off guard because
they know that she's well prepared but
sometimes the best way to meet a
stronger player is to as your mullinski
used to say stand on the shoulder of
giants you have a more classical opening
so that you know you can kind of
challenge them in their theory I always
like the classical I mean classics I
know them very well by the way arena
showing her positional prowess has in
fact played the move Knight g5 putting
direct angelina under direct pressure
Angele Angelina's facing two big threats
Bishop b4 and Bishop d5 check and our
tournament leader in the women's section
arena crush doing very well here during
round four fantastic start here for
Irina cross and looks like she might
just increase her score two four zero
right a game on board one again gata
Kamsky the only leader in the only
player army in the championships with a
perfect score when we have left the game
we left it I like this move see oops go
back a bit
I like this move f5 very much by God I
followed by c5 and at this point I felt
that God is opening problems we're all
behind him that is to say he had
equalized comfortably captures he took
with the pawn I had mentioned that
Knight takes e5 playing to secure this
outpost
efore look quite promising he took with
the pawn in order that he could support
be five and he for what you like getting
that King Sunday majority rolling and
also having a center majority the game
continued Bishop g7 Queen g7 Queen d2
direct threat against the knight got it
covered that with rookie 7 and again we
see got it classically playing through
the center
he's clearly eyeballing the e60 five
getting that epon go rolling be four
well we can understand this move White
has his own majority on the queenside
that's not very active that'd be four
I'm not sure I really like that move but
all right
he five takes Knight takes e5 frankly
this position just simply looks ideal
for black looks like a dream huh yeah if
I could get these types of decisions be
playing the Slav all day God also has
twice as much time as an opponent so so
God a cruising here e queen came to a
five part of me attacking the knight on
c5 that was a simple move rook c8
supporting the night rook e1 okay he
understand
rooks belong on open files and Conrad
hoping for a a cheapo as we would say in
the barbaric Northwest a cheapo is a
tactic which our opponent allows us to
make a tactic from time to time oh boy
now that move is quite deep rook on e7
to e8 I think it would have been taken
me a while to come around to thinking of
that as the candidate move just to
prevent the eight huh preventing perhaps
well rook da
yes but boy okay you saw it right away I
didn't think that rook d8 was a threat
the rookie ain't got his choice might
not be a threat but maybe he doesn't
want to you might not have wanted to go
for that our wholesale trade right
mm-hmm
so for example would you actually yeah I
guess no go ahead no I was just gonna
say I might have found myself attracted
to this move Bishop b4 putting some
pressure or attacking the rook directly
and we're talking about the Jeep on
virus I I started looking I started
looking for some strange reason maybe
maybe it's in the water I'm
thinking even about g5g for but okay god
I played rook da let's just see how the
game continued Knight d2
okay immediately taking efore under
control when and 93 I liked this
maneuver by Conrad because I do think
this Knight on c5 is simply too powerful
so let's get rid of that and the knight
has dropped back to e6 by the way with
ideas like Knight f4 attacking the
bishop and eyeballing the g2 pawn and c5
preparing Bishop c4 that'll be nice or a
strength I mean it's gotta just gonna
round that guy up I think we're going to
find out right right away
so c5 okay so Bishop c4 right thing I've
got ideas - it's not on copy that
Bishop takes rook a8 in some positions
but I guess it just depends on the exact
situation well you know me I'm a big
pond robber but here I would look for
activity if I were in white shoes and
rook d6 and moves like Bishop c5 are
very compelling well maybe this is a
good move then because like weights
white just wasn't getting very much play
speaking of exciting play we've got an
update on our pet dragon Oh Grand Master
where exactly okay how to train a dragon
I love that movie
well in this case how to tame a dragon
it looks as though Tata
playing boldly with white missed a big
opportunity to crush black and you
should see these lines I can't believe
the stuff the computer is coming up with
in this position the pawn went to b4 to
attack the knight and according to the
computer the best move was to actually
give away this night on a4 and after
Bishop takes simply capture on g6 and it
just looks like a lock on blacks
position the positions starting become
overwhelming this pawn on the heavy
pressure you can't really block this
diagonal
after a capture here the bishop crashes
through so this wouldn't be good for
black but the variation that's got me
mystified is this one the computer
saying maybe the best line now is
bailout of Time Queen takes and bring
this Knight back to this Square and
check this out best way to play
sacrifice the Queen excuse me let me
back up just one second
first it's capturing with check and then
bring the knight back as the line and
then sacrifice the Queen and takes and
then take on f7 with check take again
and end up a full exchange and a pawn
after this capture it's just an exchange
but it's a two rooks and the pawn thinks
this is the best line looks like it's
winning for a white crazy-crazy line
Tata have decided to sidestep all this
stuff and just play the mild move Knight
back to e2 and here the computer saying
oh she just has a slight edge if pawn
takes pawn I know you understand this
stuff yes I really don't that's light
edge I feel is predicated on black
finding a series of super accurate
defensive moves that's why I think it's
misleading I think that White has a much
bigger than slight edge in a practical
game she's playing computer sure but you
know this is uh this is chess where you
know everybody's under a ton of pressure
you don't have unlimited time it's very
different and I think that a black is in
trouble in this game yes and although
Knight takes a four was a awkward very
difficult move to find these sacrifices
with capturing on g6 and that dragon
game are so common and typical that I
would have expected something like f
takes g6 take a look at the game I think
we just I just saw something happen on
f2 alright I just wanna get on the guy
de Kamp's key game I am expecting God a
camps key to play III pawn takes Queen
III initiating an attack on White's King
let's go to the draw
taming the dragon gotta like that okay I
I like that movie too How to Train Your
Dragon I was like is this a chess the
first mainstream chest we're gonna have
some grandmasters talking about chess
openings exactly then I saw that it was
it was a cartoon but a good one
a very good animation but we might have
a mainstream chess movie we've got a
couple I mean there was a proclaim
Castle I heard there's a Cuba Gooding
jr. movie that might be coming out soon
and then I also heard which is exciting
for me as a promoter of women in chess
is that Disney is doing a movie about
Fiona Moo Tessie the girl from Uganda
who became a very strong chess player
and there was a great book of her queen
of got--we right and then isn't
Hollywood going to do a biopic on Bobby
Fischer as well yes yes fighter man
himself
going to play Bobby the lead role Wow
[Music]
exactly yeah I look forward a big movie
maybe we'll have some new students do if
people are gonna love chess after all
these movies yeah and and we've got a
night night at 92 occurred right and
then we have night f2 or work t5 first
and then night f2 right this is the
position on the board but the computer
is screaming that White has an
overwhelming advantage here so there
must be a very powerful tactical shot or
simply grabbing material is the computer
considers the position extremely
extremely favorable for white try to
figure it out so what would we start
with here I just want to try to check
meet you in the H file let's try to move
our queen in that direction like say we
just play Queen f4 and then if you take
on d1 we will just play Queen h4 anyway
and then I think the issue here might be
okay so you got to do your typical rook
e8 right right because that's the only
way out okay
are we going in with a check yeah and
then after oh no Yi sex okay I wasn't
sure about taking on g6 first but yeah
that's okay no no no go ahead you think
six is good 96 I was I was trying to
open up the F file by force
yeah with this rook f1 and I'm saying
hashtag checkmate and seven the computer
says black cannot avoid getting
checkmated in this line so your opening
salvo queen Sally Queen f4 is right on
the button
Jen and computer really likes this move
the move also that I like oftentimes
when I'm attacking I want to make sure
that everybody is invited to the party
I can see this night on e2 is not
participating in the attack but after
this move Knight f4 with a similar idea
that you have proposed bring your Queen
over to the H file and the attack plays
itself right so you could have something
similar to that line that we just saw
and maybe this move Knight Knight g6 or
even 96 really just is killing it as
well right the same the same type of
thing in this case you have to take with
the bishop this looks this looks and
again the problem is like trying to bail
out with Bishop f6 giving back some
material there's just queen s I've made
precisely Wow
so we've got some beautiful head shots
here of both players but I guess only
one player will be smiling after this
game right and it looks to be the white
player Tatia who is as we've mentioned
at the opening of the show only a mere
half point behind arena crush well
actually to be fair I should say that
Irina said you always seems to be
smiling except when she's playing chess
so I have a feeling that when we do see
her analyzing all these beautiful
variations she actually will be smiling
and that's a hallmark of people who
really love chess set they're serious at
the game they might be upset for a few
minutes afterwards but then it's post
mortem and just getting into it and
enjoying the game true true I mean the
reality is when you play chess it's it's
all about taking risks and even if
you're the best even if you're the world
champion sometimes you some
we play like an idiot and you have a
loss or two that hurts
but you ever what overcome it very
quickly it's tough to play the dragon in
a tournament where people get to prepare
for you for weeks and months in advance
you know it's like I think sometimes you
need another opening up your sleeve when
you know that your opponent thinks
you're gonna play the dragon just to try
to catch them off guard
oh yeah no I mean it's trouble
double-edged the dragon is a very
double-edged system I'm pulling up on
our board two of our most promising
junior players and as we know ray Robson
is a local goes to Webster College as
Susan Polgar I mentioned yesterday that
she came out to support Ray but Ray had
a bad day yesterday here when Maurice
has been explaining the G pawn virus has
taken over and after G for Maurice
obviously expected g5 by black how's
that like everybody getting in on the
action
with their G pawns today in today's
round four of the US Championship rook
f1 and the clever idea of Mark Arnold is
that he wanted to secure the e5 square
as we see countless times in Sicilians
for his Knight Queen takes h6h 495 there
he goes Knight is awesome on the e5
square as it protects f7 pawn and g5
interesting Knight g4 boy I am I think
my hand
I couldn't have prevented myself from
playing a move like h6 takes g5 here
only because I like the idea of opening
up the file for my rook mark Arnold felt
that Knight g4 was best
the bishop dropped back to d2 now he'd
captured captured ooh
gen would you have captured that Bishop
on d3
tonight only five looks fantastic but
that being said if there is a there
could be a concrete reason for it maybe
he just wants to put his other night
there you know they what they call the
superfluous Nani uh-huh
so you thought maybe after Knight takes
d 395 29 to d3 check maybe he assesses
out that was good for a black okay we're
the best a black can do so what would Y
do here we don't want to protect that
pawn by with with our King we probably
want to move our Bishop rather on d2 to
protect it I would think like with a
Bishop III or something don't forget
that knight on e5 is stretched it's got
its duty defensive duty protecting the
pawn on f cking b1 right which is a move
that you kind of wanted to play anyway
precisely and Ray did take that
opportunity to play King b1 just also by
the way the room they just slide over to
the C file where it would be on an open
file and threatened a discovery against
the Queen rook f8 by the way now does
open up the knight takes T three queen
drop back to g3 to protect the pawn on
d3 g interesting decision by mark and
rook c1 so now with this nasty move rook
c1 the move Knight d5 starts to be
extremely attractive
oh boy well now maybe black wants to
play Queen b8 attacking g5 but that
looks bad seizing the defensive yeah I
mean we are attacking something but it
looks this retreating move I'm just not
so sure about even if even if I'm white
just plays like you're gay yeah when did
you become a pawn grubber
that explains it but you are walking
into a pen you take that pawn you may be
saying you may feel your fingers
scorched a little bit Bishop takes g5
does walk into a nasty pen after work do
you wanna yeah I'm thinking that this
knight on e5 is actually too dominant
my knight on beef
three does not impress how about a move
like Knight d4 inviting you to capture
this the idea straightforward as it is
is I want to get rid of this knight on
e5 if I can provoke you to trade I have
exposed this d6 pawn right and that and
if I don't train and I play f6 instead
you mean here just simply f7 f6
oh boy oh boy I'm losing something I see
you can I guess you can take on g5 with
the bishop but then maybe at that point
take on f3 no oh you're taking with a
knight I think you set yourself up for a
major slash looking pretty good for Rey
and we've got as Maurice Ashley with a
scratch your head moment Oh DJ we had a
wild position that we were following in
Shabalala versus honest shook and we
know Shambhala was an aggressive player
a forward-thinking player not the kind
of guy to stop and when he's in the
middle of an attack unless it's
absolutely called for but in this game
he played a move that's gotten me
scratching my head in this position he
did take the knight and yeah so you had
liked in this position the move rook
takes on d5 which the computer approves
of as well instead he backed down and
played the move Bishop to b2 and that
slowing down the attack and allowing
this D pawn to stay on the board is
decidedly frowned on by the computer and
now the move rook to e8 Queen d2 has
been played in the game and now this D
pawn gets its revenge d4 marching down
the board it's cemented in the position
Knight to e2 has been played and we're
waiting now but the computer likes
Bishop to g4 setting up all kinds of
action on this diagonal and this D pawn
may be a big curse now in in White's
position he would have wished he had
gotten rid of it one line to show is if
the move h3 trying to get rid of this
Bishop this variation fails badly after
95 and if you move your bishop back
suddenly Knight to c4 and the Queen
cannot hang on to everything
this deep on again looking to march down
the board well even that rook takes nine
as possible so why did he play Bishop to
be to a sort of rook takes d5 we're
gonna have to ask him after the game but
maybe a bad loss for him things started
to turn in blacks favor Jenny yes if
that pawn structure by the way reminds
me of the game that Shabalala
won against her gay husband earlier in
the tournament when we thought she ball
off was lost and he admitted he actually
got lucky in that game and here he is
back to the same thing the same type of
tactics but I totally agree with Maurice
grabbing that D pawn with the tempo
earlier looked obligatory I mean this is
just not a very nice position for white
and that line I just wanted to point out
another nice little tactic covariation
was that if in this case after 95
attacking the bishop if you were to play
Knight takes d4 cleverly one might think
defending the bishop you can see this my
job give up the lady right I think you
see in a lot of books on double attack
right and for my lectures with the
children especially they just love the
so-called Royal fork knight on f3
attacking White's king and queen
simultaneously black would win the game
instantly in this line of play so I
think Shambhala is in deep trouble here
and we do have a result alert Grand
Master Larry Christensen has defeated
John Bryan and moves to three out of
four so despite losing a game they got a
calm ski Larry Christian very much in
the high end with three wins and you
know it's very hard to rack up three
wins in this tournament the u.s.
championship everyone he's out to get
you though he's playing tough opposition
to big Larry coming through smash
swashbuckle only here I know that John
was
was doing poorly out of the opening that
this move Bishop d5 really secured the
wheels video yeah that pawns just just a
goner home run there for Larry
Christensen and well we get him set up
I'm gonna take a little a Twitter
question for you Yaser and that's at the
hashtag us chest champs okay the
question is Yasser I saw you playing the
US Championship in South Bend Indiana in
1981 can you comment on how this event
has changed since then well thank you
for the question first of all I'm very
very pleased and delighted to say I
think it's just gotten better and better
and better the US Championships as we
know this is the fifth year in a row
they've found a home in st. Louis and I
can tell you that the organizers here
take this event so seriously a month of
preparation went into the layout the
actual setup of our operations the whole
internet revolution and what that meant
for the broadcasting of the games in
real time live this is it's marvelous to
see this evolution taking place in the
u.s. champions you're saying that in
1981 you didn't have a twitter followers
asking your questions that's right
amazingly you know I didn't I didn't and
I just really enjoy what the Internet
has meant for the broadcast of chests
oftentimes chess and television haven't
married well the internet is perfect
just perfect you can archive all the
games play them over at your convenience
instant access it's just it's just
marvelous
well and also the the TV tip is going
well as well Fox Sports Midwest is gonna
be doing a one-hour show on this
championship and of course you can also
find the live stream on their website I
can't wait to see the one hour show I
know we've captured enormous amounts of
archive video tape is gonna be a fun
show please watch and let's uh hand it
over to Grand Master Maurice Ashley who
is with Larry Christians in Thank You
Jen well we're here with Larry
Christianson Bigler
congratulations in your victory today
thank you John Bryan had been doing
quite well in this tournament fabulously
while in fact as a feat a master but
today he played a bit of a howler it
looks like yeah he made an early mistake
and he never recovered I mean I just got
the initiative which led to a pawn win
of a pawn plus a dominating position he
may have put up a slightly tougher
resistance but if the game was in the
bag pretty early
when were you shocked when you saw this
move 96 Astron are with everything I was
pleasantly surprised not the right
answer well this turned out to be a very
easy game 25 moves not much to sweat
especially the dark their order
especially coming off yesterday that
must have been really disappointing you
seem to have a decent position but a lot
of fighting chances yesterday oh yeah I
think dad a tremendous game well this is
against God it comes against God I he
played very possibly in the opening
I got a nice position I there's some end
game artists squeezed artists like yeah
sorry should I could a tag team
hey yeah sir you you take over from here
he would have put that game out away I
think and then I you know overlooked a
little tactic he then it got very messy
I don't know what was going on I haven't
I didn't bother analyzing it I don't
want to you know revisit bad memories
it was a tough but you know game I don't
like reading the comments you know any
of that stuff that's that's all history
trying to move on from there indeed so
you came back with a smashing victory
you're now on three out of four which
was you right back in the hunt right how
are you feeling about your prospects
moving forward well it's still early in
the tournament I'm guardedly optimistic
I just have to today I'm gonna rest
maybe do the go to the gym for an hour
and for half an hour maybe two walk in
the park this was a walk in the park too
indeed but a real walk in the park
and sorry John and just take it easy
after that well some days they get you
and some days you get down I have to
confess yesterday after losing I visited
Lester's briefly and
booty's well a couple yeah all right
well congratulations on your victory
today and best of luck in the rest of
the tournament Thank You Maurice all
right back to you Jenna yes it's just
wonderful to see a veteran like Larry of
so many u.s. championships he doesn't
play drawers drawers drawers are for
sissies three wins out of four
outstanding really great to see that yes
wonderful so Grand Master Larry
Christiansen our young veteran Reata for
our very young spirited veteran now
speaking of youth
we've got birthday boy Keenan troph
turning 15 today facing off against
Alexander ina Ivanov who is the senior
champion that's how he got into this
tournament besides winning the u.s.
Senior Open so this is a classic battle
and it seems like both of them have used
quite a lot of time we're only on move
16 and we're two and a half hours into
the time control exactly a youth versus
grizzled age and experience
Alexander Evon off grand master for a
better part of about 3540 years he's
playing the birthday boy today and I
must say I actually like Hayden's
position the the computers are assessing
the position as a smidgen of an
advantage for black but I tell you in
practical games this is a very hard
position for black oh yeah it looks like
our reverse friend precisely and this
night on f4 is on the near ideal outpost
well White's Bishop isn't doing that
great a job the reality is it's tying
this Bishop on c8 at the defense of the
f5 pawn upon me White has basically only
one problem to solve if he could play
the move Bishop b4 and trade the dark
square Bishop so I actually think that
white is doing great hence that is why
the computer likes this move a5 to stop
bishop typical French mover right if we
were on the black side of the French it
would be a Bishop b5 line and you played
lines like
before in your past right devyn [ __ ]
basics champion of those lines my whole
career in fact and so after castles the
again the computer does like blacks
position alexander Ivana's only by a
smidgen but I'll take the birthday boy
in this particular position
I like whites came and Kayden's doing
very well all right and let's uh let's
switch games here I think we've got
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley with Sam
sevens game for virus is definitely
traveling around the room you know when
you have the flu the kids in the room
all get sick well apparently it's
happened here because in the seven well
the more husband game Sam seve on has
the black pieces and here of course you
could guess it the move G for was played
a little bit more sensible in this
situation the positions more blocked
white is securing the night on f5 so
here not so dramatic
however another situation brewing that
we definitely want to pay attention to
as a sacrifice alert in this position
that looked extraordinarily calm black
had blocked up everything that white was
trying to demonstrate over on the Kings
side and was now starting to get his own
play on the other side of the board well
Benjamin would have none of it and
decided it's time for me to sacrifice
Bishop takes h5 and if this captures
back then here comes the Queen over
there looking to play g6 and maybe get
an attack going it doesn't look all that
clear maybe Bishop back a bishop to have
five is playable ninety three Bishop
back to g6 but still there might be some
play if the Queen hangs around with h5
coming so in this position after Bishop
takes h5 this sacrifice the computer
saying you can have the pawn let's just
keep playing on the Queen side will that
happen pretty bizarre stuff wild things
happening today at the championship
Jenna yes Thank You Mari so an exciting
sacrifice in the Benjamin version game
so where are we at in the position
Bishop takes h5 Bishop takes h5 has been
played and as Maurice was saying
churring the bishop gives white inroads
on the kingside and may be opportunities
for better repetition interestingly the
computer which of course loves material
in this particular case says stop back
up for a moment let's not capture this
bishop but rather let's continue with
rook c8 and try to create a weakness on
the Queen side and we can say we can see
pardon me white doesn't have a lot of
pieces over here on the Queen side and
if black can follow up with moves like
Queen before he's the one with the
initiative and in fact the computer
saying this is good for black well I
think Parisian is gonna go for this line
he seems like the type who plays the
French with the idea to get activity not
that not to be miserable and yeah I
think this this game is he's gonna
continue to be interesting but I do
believe that version is going to reject
the sacrifice all right well yeah yeah
it's tough when your opponent starts
throwing their pieces against you most
of the time I like to take them but in
this particular case it does make sense
rook c8 and let's say the line would
continue rook c3 and probably just going
after this pawn on c3 yes I think so I'm
not maybe
maybe with the Queen no because we get
all that activity goes yeah the other
way yeah you know they just go for it
maybe we're getting there first let's
just see since we don't mind a Queen
trade in any variation so that helps our
cause tremendously well in this
particular line we can see how blacks
queen has made tremendous inroads over
here with green c1 check i if i drop
back with a queen you will capture this
pawn on c3 and you will have an
advantage no doubts about it so not the
great game going on here Hut between two
top class grandmasters and let's take
another look at our dragon we've got a
Irina's on nuke and patella rouhani on
all right let me just the women's
championship we really like the position
for Wyatt we didn't think that the
dragon was going to survive and it looks
like white did play one of the lines
that we were discussing instead of the
night f4 which you guys liked even more
Queen f4 with the blunt idea of Queen to
h4 and checkmate on a cha men hard to
prevent because you've got these nice
little ninety-six moves at the end
cracking open another file in blacks
face so what what happened we did get
all of these moves now Tates tat tips to
play and she's trying to figure out what
she wants to do here but it looks like
one of those situations where maybe
everything wins right what if she just
plays the more obvious looking move
because ninety-six is a little there's a
little fancier like what if she just
plays takes on Queen eight seven and
then takes on g6 does that also win that
looks awesome as well I mean again
you're just Jan you're just opening up
the F file and you want to bring your
rook across from the h1 square to the f1
square and just crash down over here on
f7 and that also very straightforward
play will do it you don't have to be
fancy okay and now let's let's see how
the so let's see how this one if pawn
takes g6 pawn takes g6
rook f1 Shaq okay you could probably put
your knight in the way for a moment but
okay assuming you were to play Bishop f6
the line I like actually very
straightforward is night check Bishop
takes pawn takes and there's no possible
defense to Queen f7 check and mate it
just looks like Tata is crushing here
we're getting a note here from master
Horace actually that there's actually a
mate in 23 so and here there is a mating
- I mean just have nice use have 93 Jack
right nice you three check and that's
your desperado followed by right Queen
f7 mate in the barbaric Northwest we
would call the move Knight c3 a spike
check and it's it's it's it's over I
mean
fantastic game by Tocqueville bhajami on
we are talking about how Irina crushes
playing so fantastically but you know
Tata nipping at her heels without
question and in this game I admire them
both arena zhenya came to the game I
think very very well-prepared she had a
shot she was in there with a puncher's
chance but I think she just
misunderstood
that in this position the move rook
takes d5 she couldn't afford a single
misstep and she had this opportunity of
capturing on pardon me on f5 and that
would have been mm much more of a
challenge for wife 494 earlier or 94
earlier twice she had those
opportunities missed them both and
unfortunately in the position that she
currently has on the board I think she
simply lost you just can't make too many
mistakes when you're training your
dragon very good and shall we see what's
happening on the first board in the US
Women's Championship arena crush as we
know perfect score we loved her position
earlier when she when we left has she
improved it this was the position we
laughed when I was pointing out that
this move Bishop b4 angling to snap off
this pawn on h7 was in the air Angelina
Bishop e7 she's been playing that bit
darks where Bishop around a lot normally
you get punished when you ignore the
rest of your pieces
well the idea there is that it stops
Bishop to e4 because then rook takes g5
and unlike many of the imbalances we've
seen elsewhere in this competition and
the two pieces would be a way more
powerful than the rock so that would be
very bad for a marina so instead she's
forced to just retreat her Knight so I
actually think this was a good idea by
Angelina because the bishop on g6
imprisoning her bishop on c8 was not
leaving much of an impression true that
I couldn't agree with you more all
across the board you know somehow I like
that night on g5 now I'm going to
probably been very tempted to keep it
there at least for one extra ply this
move h4 because I like this Bishop b4
threat if you play h6 I think about that
yeah reasonable move how about on me
how about first of all tossing out this
Bishop Shak probably provoking you into
the corner correct mm-hmm and then how
about Bishop back to e4 attacking this
rook and then we're forced to backtrack
right rook at probably Fe rook to f8 now
is there anything I can mmm this is what
I was angling for a little you just put
it on the board so folks can see how I
fantasize I mean it's not the greatest
square of course for the night that I'm
trying I'm trying to go after work out 7
bishop g6 or something well precisely
rook f7 I was actually angling for Queen
h5 may be threatening ideas what you
mentioned 6 Bishop h6 but it looks like
I can just play the weird-looking brick
g8 cuz your pieces your pieces are so
miss coordinated now I think I'm
threatening now I think I'm just running
g6 really okay yeah that's I mean your
Knights you basically trap your own
night well without question and you
don't have time to play I mean I guess
you could well maybe you could play h5
here right locking down as you say to
prevent your g6 and the play Bishop g6
yourself perhaps right that would be a
nice anchor square for my bishop so an
interesting possibility yeah I have to
see sometimes lead you somewhere I'm not
sure that I I'm happy with the night on
h7 then again it may end up being a
brilliant square but that would did not
happen so let's go to and see what how
the game has unfolded since 94 bishop
ace
Peg's Angelina is playing uncompromising
chess she's not trying to clarify the
position at all nights III go going
after this squared D 5 up why is he
getting her King outta Dodge
King h8 and now arena is playing
classically she took the two bishops but
then immediately gave up the bishop on
g2 so treating one time advantage for
another kind so she trades the kind of
dynamic advantage of the two bishops for
the more static permanent advantage of
playing against blacks weak pawns so
this is going to be a interesting
strategic battle here is Irina crushed
going to squeeze and Alena to death we
will find out but first we have an
instructive moment from grandmaster
Maurice Ashley well Jen there are
situations in chess where the natural
move isn't the right move it happens
quite often and one of the things I
remember a quote from Viktor Korchnoi
that you know you're becoming a strong
player when you start playing the
exceptions to the rule as opposed to
playing the natural moves that seem like
those are the ones that would work and
in this situation illness truck had a
fantastic position it looks you know to
all the world like he has all the
compensation he's got all these pawns
and what's the missing element for him
the one thing he wants to do is take
this pawn on c7 and Ram it down White's
throat just go down the board as fast as
possible so he needs to move this night
away from Eve away from c6 in the game
he chose to move Knight to e5 and the
computer frowns on this move because it
relieves white a little bit by being
allowing him to trade here he's still a
little better for black and maybe enough
to win the game but ownership had a much
better move a paradoxical 1/9 - a5
guarding this pawn on b3 and leaving
this pawn undefended for the moment his
intention is still to play the move c5
and in fact you cannot capture this pawn
with your knight because of the move c5
and the knight has no safe place to go
anywhere it goes it requires the defense
of the Queen so for example the move
Knight to f5 would run into Queen takes
Queen rook takes and even this Bishop is
hanging also this Knight is hanging
on f5 so it couldn't play there actually
there's no good place for it to go the
pin is on on this long diagonal as well
so too much happening so the point is
untouchable
and so after Knight a5 c5 will happen so
we'll see for and those parts are just
gonna rain and so I missed move a missed
opportunity here for 4 owners Chuck he
instead played the move Knight to e5 and
this is where the position sits computer
saying now only 0.98 advantages opposed
to the 2-point a two point five I
believe well over two which would have
been much more in his favor
so those paradoxical moves you got to
look for them instead of just playing
the natural ones
Jen Thank You Maurice I got a share
story about Viktor Korchnoi because
Maurice made a quote on Viktor so many
stories great stories about Viktor one
of the wonderful things about this
octogenarian Viktor Korchnoi who still
is with us blessedly Viktor took a lot
of junior players as his coach junior
players and I asked him about and he
said well the junior players bring
passion to chess and make him feel
youthful so he liked their passion and
took a lot of a large number of juniors
under his wing including yours truly but
one story comes from john van der Wiel
john van de ville and Victor were
studying preparing for one of Victor's
big matches and john van de ville from
holland it offered a suggestion in a
very strategic game when an anti
positional move and victor looked at
John and said John before you violate
the rules of strategy you should first
know them the great put down and just
loved it I've ATG tells a story with
with great joy today and it's true you
first you should know the rules and then
you know how to violate the rules and
why you're violating the rules but this
was a very good
nation there by Maurice when the move
knight c6 285 moving the knight out of
the center usually that's frowned upon
but in this case the exception would
have given it looks like only shook a
massive advantage indeed and it's also a
badge of honor to be insulted by a
legend absolutely it goes both ways
right and I did want to remind everyone
hashtag us chest champs for questions
and comments on the broadcast and also
award Jake our who had a question for
Yasser earlier a one-year membership to
chess calm we're also giving out ICC
memberships so nice keep those questions
and comments coming we and let's go -
yeah let's go to our board one in the US
Championship Conrad Hall and gata Kamsky
absolutely here we've got them on the
webcam looks like Conrad's doing some
some yoga and stretching Rizzo there was
a good article in the u.s. yes u.s. you
have website about chess and yoga so
yeah maybe Conrad read up on that and
it's kind of stretching themselves out
what was the conclusion Yoga is good for
your chest well the idea is that chess
can be bad for your posture so yoga is a
good you know kind of complement to that
he's ready to keep you balanced in that
way very cool well when we left it
remember we saw this move c5 with the
ideas of rook to d6 as well as Bishop to
c4 I predicted God it would play III
which is going after White's King this
Bishop opens up magnificently on this
long diagonal like coming to f4 Queen
coming to the party
you've got to invite the Queen to the
party oh you bet so after the move III
Conrad felt obliged to capture it can't
blame them for that one Queen gold
embossed invitation here for the Queen
yes your majesty please enter a threat
alert Queen g3 going after a checkmate
as well as the obvious Queen captures
III check that was ready to threaten
retinue threatened threatened to
threaten is big though I think that
sometimes the people
don't see the the checkmate threats so
you're playing a move that threatens to
me uh-huh
and that's that's something that
sometimes people miss well in this case
is really you know like flashing red yes
especially with your arrows
okay Queen d2 looks like a box move what
we would say is a forced move as white
feels compelled to now go on the
defensive and luckily also getting the
Queen back to the defense of g2 so now
after Queen g3 we can move our Bishop on
C on e - and the the mate would be
defended right so we should point out
that at least Conrad Hall is getting got
a thinking because before Gatto was up a
whole half-hour and now they've pretty
much evened out on the clocks mm-hmm
yeah having said all that and the
computer I can tell you the computer
sits there and says hey this positions
quite defensible only a smidgen of an
advantage for gada I mean as a human
player I would see moves like Queen g3
threatened directly checkmate and if we
drop the bishop back probably a bad move
by the way by g5
with ideas of night a3 check and Knight
h3 I would get out of it just get out of
it with King edge wrong right you know
if there's another pin that's that yeah
I mean that's a problem when you play
came to H you're gonna pin now with the
night takes h3 threat and if you play
King H wine you're still in a pin
because of that beautiful Bishop wanna
b7 which we've seen in so many other
games and while it's not quite
checkmating it looks pretty bad
it does and again Knight f3 mate night
after winning the Queen the computer
doesn't seem to be impressed by all of
these threats but as a human player I
really would favor goddess position and
if he does win this game guess what he's
a horrible
yeah well I'm running away from the
field and are you believe unning away
with the Bobby Fischer prize he's got an
eye on the prize that's sure I feel like
once he gets to 500 it's definitely you
know in his mind that's at this point
you know I think it's people most of the
players
things like all it's impossible to get
that but if he gets a five oh it's gonna
be serious business now let's point out
he hasn't played a lot of the most solid
and strong players in the tournament he
hasn't played his Olympic teammates I'm
Alexander ownership who especially with
the white pieces will be a very hard nut
to crack and then version of Kobe in
neither so that's those are some and
that's not to mention some other very
strong players yeah gray of Benjamin yes
so there there's Shulman I mean there's
a lot of good players he hasn't played
yet and in fact you could argue that
he's playing against one of the less
experienced players this round which is
true but okay Conrad to his credit is
playing well oh yeah if the guy goes
rampage exactly your entities that he's
playing on board well with good reason
and something has been captured well
let's see what happened well instead of
going for the Queen g3 approach got a
played rook c8 to d8 which okay makes
perfect sense going after the Queen
Queen dropped back God if he wanted at
this moment could have won his pawn but
with check that would have precipitated
Queen F to Bishop d5 God is keeping all
of his notice the harmony by the way of
God his attacking forces right all the
places are very well placed and
everything protects each other so you
don't have to worry about those pesky
loose pieces sign the man master hand
let's put it that way and I think we
were up to date probably not I actually
think that Connor had grabbed something
I believe he actually played Bishop
takes a six so really he grabbed another
pawn and now gata Kamsky is at a two
point deficit but lots of threats in the
position and what about some checkmate
threats here let's take a look well
let's see what do you like you like
lining up between Queenie for okay oops
I do pop I have a little hiccup at the
moment just a second oh but we I mean oh
you've got it you got a hiccup yeah but
I mean I do I did hear that we have a
move actually that he didn't play
Queenie for I guess on Queenie for
threatening the check
meet down you just figured perhaps that
um what you could just defend it with
Queen to f2 reasonable but then then I
was thinking maybe something like ninety
five threatening Knight takes h3 that's
what I was hoping for but I'm sure there
were a number other defenses after Queen
e4 and so instead God apparently has
played work to a8 alright just a second
let me just do something flummoxed here
by this position yes we do have a tweet
here from Phillip go who goes by math
casualty on Twitter all right that's a
that's a fun name and he mentioned that
the structure in Feingold Norah wits
again that we haven't looked at yet
between a newcomer to the championship
Yaakov Nora wits and st. Louis local
then Feingold he said that that Nate
game is reminiscent of Nakamura
Lenderman twenty twelve that epic game
which was a hundred and twenty one move
draw and he asks why do they play almost
a hundred moves less well I'll have to
pull up that game later but yeah that
was a pretty incredible performance by
Lenderman who is not playing this year
but I think he's trying to qualify for
the World Cup instead absolutely with
with good reason I mean I like
Slenderman was an exit he he played
excellently last year in the u.s.
championship didn't make this year's US
Championship but as you point out
correctly it's going to be playing in
the World Cup knockout Championships the
feed a world championship cycle and so
we wish him a great deal good luck on
the webcam I see we've got been fine
goals position looks like it's going to
race so I don't know he says why did it
finish but yeah it's still still going
strong and looks like it'll be an
interesting game and we also have
Grandmaster Morris actually for more on
our top board struggle well I'm paying
attention to this game as much as you
guys obviously and I've been looking
at some of these finer points here with
the computer to just understand it and
it looks as though Conrad is playing
brilliantly in defense it's really
amazing how he's holding off this
world-class Grandmaster one of the top
players in the world first of all this
move queen g3 which looks really
attractive y can actually just defend
with Bishop to c4 keeping that night out
of the game and the Queen defends
laterally on g2 and is ready to help out
that King that pin just to annoying it
turns out now after rooks cd8 Queen to
e1 computer doesn't think this move is
that special Bishop to d5 but
materialistic indeed Bishop takes on a6
and if you look at this although blacks
pieces are well harmonized you can look
and everything about it is gorgeous
he is down to pawns it's a lot of pawns
and in fact after his move which is the
move given by the computer as best rook
a 8th Bishop to f1 guards everything
there's no checkmate happening anytime
soon
and after this capture black really
doesn't have anything super concrete and
it looks as though white might be able
to get back pretty rapidly with a
maneuver like this one night back and
then improve this night chasing the
Queen away and now it's not so easy it's
just not and black is still down upon
with a lot to prove so just a few moves
away from totally consolidating is young
Conrad Holt and putting his more
experienced a grandmaster his feet to
the fire pretty good position Jenna has
impressive defense by Conrad because
truth be told a lot of grandmasters
would just simply collapse under what
seems like fantastic attacking play by
gada Kamsky and as Maurice has been
pointing out white is material ahead
gada has recaptured the pawn he didn't
play maurices Bishop f1 which well
instead he played the move Bishop b5
very intriguing move e5 interesting yeah
just going after and then black just
took the pawn on a 2 anyway
allowing bishop takes a a which I I
guess was assessed to be quite poor
after which later on rook takes g2 and
Queen h2 it's a it's like the
checkmating
attack just plays itself right or
checkmates on the board and their worst
case work takes Bishop and Queen h1
would just be checkmate
exactly we'll put that on just for our
audience we got it
we've actually got a choice of three
mates in one yeah what does it say about
me which we're Queen h1 was my first
instinct I don't want to get too close
to you I want to crush you from afar I'm
not that bad I'm a nice guy yesterday
from Lindenwood so that she was
extremely jealous of me sitting next to
you your silver tongue ah there you go
well the computer did not like Conrad it
it loved what Conrad had been doing up
to this precise moment and he didn't
like this move Bishop b5 preferring
maurices defensive retreat Bishop f1
just keeping this pawn under right onto
that pond so that after rook takes a
two-night c1
since g2 is protected it gives us it
gives white the time he needs to bring
his knight back into play
I don't know that looks like a starting
position from Fischer random put that
back on the boy with me bishop f1 and
then Knight C 1 because we commented
together on a fitter random competition
that's something that usually Queen kvq
here at the st. Louis chess club so
after work a two-night c1 this looks
exactly like a starting position for
Fischer random and yet not too bad for
white sometimes retreats are not awful
right again that whole leg when to break
the rules idea there you go
but dead Bishop b5 and again we talked
earlier about how loose pieces often are
kind of an alarm signal so you want to
be extra sure when you put up square on
a piece and a square that's not defended
that you've got all year
it's covered exactly well this is not
covering up let's put it that way and
the computer already thinks that despite
the fact that white is ahead of material
computer says blacks attack is now
taking on alarming proportions and gada
has an advantage and I tell you when
you're under pressure and you're facing
you know the highest seed in the
tournament and this is your rookie year
we hope that Conrad can find the moves
to stave off the feat but it's gonna be
hard well I'm not so excited because
that means that God is gonna be able to
have some fun and we're gonna be able to
see some more cool checkmating
variations they don't happen we'll be
able to enjoy them and we've got Maurice
Ashley with an update on the gray of
game well more than an update this is an
astonishing move as you'll ever see in a
chess game take a look at this the last
move played was rook to d4 the rook is
obviously attacking White's Queen
why does a very simple movie a rook
takes on d4 and after pawn takes then
just play Knight to e4 threatening to
put the knight in to the d6 square for
King the Queen and the rook real simple
no big deal okay you did straight now
blacks pawns but your pieces are still
good and computer says white has a
decent advantage of 0.78 but showman
panicked here and thought that move was
terrible and he evaluated it as just a
poor position for him and instead he
replied with just a move that makes you
fall off your chair he played the move
Knight to g6 with his Queen still under
attack he drops his knight in on the g6
square obviously cannot be captured
because of this pin on this diagonal but
what about taking the Queen well it
turns out rook to e8 check King up and
now Knight of 7 check and after King
back he just plans to draw by playing
perpetual check an astonishing way to
draw the game especially considering
that white was actually better I mean he
went crazy
Jenny yes sometimes you just make a
misjudgment on the position I think URI
just had a momentary misjudgment there
he didn't realize that his position was
actually just fine as Maurice pointed
out he saw this repetition with Knight
g6 and said okay I'll make a draw
because I'm worse when he wasn't so
that's just a big Mis judgment missed
call well as we get up from our chairs
you're going to take a quick break and
we'll be right back with more chess and
action from the u.s. chess championships
and u.s. women's here in st. Louis
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello here at the US Chess Championships
we have some results going into the
third hour of play and we have
grandmaster Sam chenkin who's gonna be
talking with Maryse in just a minute but
we also have halt Kamsky and the
situation here is starting to clarify it
looks like halt screwed up huh yes he
did well a popular question from
reporters to me is what separates
grandmasters from another why is one
Grandmaster better than another there
are thousand good answers one I like to
say is that some grandmasters know a lot
of positions better than other
grandmasters another one is simply that
some grandmasters calculate better than
in others in this position that we see
in front of our screens Bishop b5 was
played by Conrad and he had calculated
what he thought was a winning variation
for him he saw this movie for expected
that he would be able to capture this
rook and felt that the position was
winning unfortunately for him in the
words of Bobby Fischer he missed the
scorpion sting at the end of the tail
checkmate threat is a g2 and Knight f4
are devastating checkmating ideas Conrad
was forced to give back the bishop and
in this position the computer assesses
the position is completely one
completely winning for gada Kamsky well
yeah that e to pawn is just too powerful
I mean sorry III a Freudian slip
coming to e2 surely though wow so it
looks like gotta Kamsky was gonna start
this tournament with four wins fantastic
and we have another winner today with
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley and that's a
grandmaster Sam chenkin who joins us for
the first time on this broadcast thanks
June with Grandmaster Sam Shanklin
congratulations on your win today thank
you
how's it been so far in the tournament
for you how would you assess how you've
been playing well I think I've played
quite well actually I mean I know I lost
so Conrad in round one which was an
upset but I was kind of beating myself
up that night for losing that game but I
just looked at it lay us
Connor I just played like a genius you
deserve to win and I think I've been
playing decently and after a relatively
slow start things are moving in the
right direction how has it been we noted
that there are at least five collegians
in the in the men's section in the
championship section how's it been
trying to deal with the fact that you
just had a few papers to write finals to
take and then come to play chess with
the sharks
it's been very difficult I took three
exams in the two days before the US
Championship which is really tough norm
I'd want to be resting more but you have
to make some sacrifices on both ends if
you want to be a semi-professional
professional chess player as well as a
college student and probably I could
have spent more time studying for my
exams and I also could have spent more
time preparing for this tournament but
you have to make your choices and I'm
pretty happy the way things have turned
out now you've just won the sanford
fellowship which is a scholarship and
fellowship money so you'll be able to
study chest full-time and and really
pursue the career are you gonna be able
to study chess full-time still with
being a student at Brandeis well while
I'm at Brandeis it'll be a little bit
tougher but I think that I've managed to
study a fair amount while I'm in school
and I've improved a lot while I've been
in school when I came to school I was
rated 2498 fidei I'm now 26 12 so
clearly I was able to improve and also
keep in mind that the Stanford is two
years it's 24 months and only seven of
those 24 months will be shared of the
school so I don't think it will present
a problem cool so what are your thoughts
about the tournament going forward after
four rounds you now have I'm dama +12
about of for two and a half what are you
thinking about your chances moving
forward well I mean comm skew seems like
a complete juggernaut right now but uh
you know I don't really like to think
about chances to win the tourney I think
like that I just like to take it one
game at a time and that's been working
for me so far but I'm reasonably
satisfied with my play I think if I keep
things up keep on playing the way I've
been playing the last two games and
catch some good breaks you know stranger
things have happened
professional attitude will
congratulations on your victory today
good luck in the rest of the tournament
next much back to you Jenna yes thank
you
and we do have some more results coming
in today Sabina for sure has a defeated
chung-kai Dena and cocky on me to draw
and Abraham Yan and that exciting dragon
also defeated Zen you can we saw that
coming for quite a few move
that was a real slaughter and I can't
wait to your what type of has to say
about that with Maurice and we also have
official result in the Kamsky game
Kamsky has defeated halt and moves to
4-0
what a fantastic start by a number one
seed here gata Kamsky absolutely I think
God will count his lucky stars today as
his opponent may have met a terrible
miscalculation as it turns out in what
had been a pretty well played game by
Conrad had he played that defense of
retreat Bishop f1 I'm sure he would have
held the game instead he went for more
and he came up empty-handed by the way
Sam Shanklin I really think is one of
the great American talents really he
played fantastically well in Brazil for
the US team as it qualified in the Pan
Am's for the World Team Championship
thanks to Sam's
excellent performance there so it's
great that he won the Sanford fellowship
program it's a two-year grant as Sam
mentioned awarded to the most talented
person in American chess so it's great
to have Sam playing in the tournament
and being a full-time college student
makes it that much harder but you're
right
Bravo gotta as he is the Jew cannot of
the moment at 4-0 yes fantastic and I
agree with you about Sam you know I've
avoided until now about making a cheesy
pun with Sam Ford oh but also you know
we've got a another interesting game
that people have been requesting as we
set up some of our star interviews here
I've been getting some requests for
Ramirez and Hass so another two of our
our young stars but not quite as young
as some of the participants in this
event but some it is it does look pretty
interesting both very popular players
and a number of players have been asking
us to look at this game you might want
to split skip closer to the end because
I don't think we're gonna have time to
look through at all okay it had a lot of
themes that were familiar
to the first board got a Kamsky and
Conrad whole game
I love these nights on ePHI by the way
great outpost with the move f5 Robert
has I think is under a lot of pressure
here is he's facing a devastating King
side attack
please note especially for these our
amateurs in our audience how those
bishops are aimed at Robert esses King
yes and it's true that the night on f8
defends but F takes c6 took care of that
momentarily that was quite a leap of
faith there with that move Knight f95
pardon me by Alejandro he must have felt
that he had some oh you just wanted to
win upon over here on the Queen side
okay very strange things are hectic will
paddle field and f7 hanging oh that
doesn't look good
another Donnybrook look at this the
discovered check for is adequately
protected although I guess so what
happens on on work takes c4 what kind of
oh you just you just recapture with the
rook before I attacked the Queen and
this rook is hanging yes I was trying to
take on c4 and then take on f7 but after
work takes c4 it's a tempo exactly but
check this out Bishop c5 cutting the
coordinate cutting the protection of the
Wow
inviting a discover check and black has
his own discover checks in mind so we
could get like a check check type
situation right I like that like for
instance not that we would do it anyway
but it's so rare that we should put on
the board if Knight takes d 8 surely
check black would surely take one c4 but
it's kind of its kind of cool yeah we
can we can take with another check check
check so haha not an everyday occurrence
exactly and I don't know if that's the
best continuation vote it's sure is fun
so we actually do have on the board so
far is just Bishop takes Bishop to c5
right now it's Ramirez
well we well the computer does like
capturing the rook
but it prefers interestingly enough not
to make the discover cheque at once but
rather to first play Queen takes c4 not
quite your wife yeah why what so let's
try to figure out why am y work takes c4
is so terrible
maybe there's simply just want to know
we've got some threats of our own here
undoubtedly Queen e6 check is a strong
thread and oops that smother mate might
come up again exactly and after rook
efore Queen 3 the computer just reckons
that with the extra exchange white is
doing exceedingly well that sure that's
all it is it's always important to keep
track of the material sometimes when
positions are so wild you just kind of
forget like the material is important
myself in exchange so in the dust clears
that's gonna be good alright so why
can't we just simply consolidate here -
what's the difference
let's take a look Queen the difference
here we still are up in exchange but it
is good here maybe porn night up to
check kind of ideas and maybe a
repetition or something of that nature
because keep in mind rook takes f2 won't
be permitted there'll be a background
check mate true and it's and it's not
easy for you to make left h3 Falls
tonight g3 and g3 and G X Q's me pardon
me 94 g3 in this moment Jennifer yes
maybe I can just simply slide down with
red c2 and again supporting perpetual
check ideas so with plenty of counter
play here in some very poorly
coordinated pieces by white black seems
to be somehow holding on so fascinating
tactical battle and thanks to those of
you online who are fans of these two
players and pointed out Stu the slugfest
there's been so many exciting games
we've we've been missing some of them
and that's a good sign about how great
this tournament is and now we have the
big star here so far at the championship
we've got a got a camp ski who now has a
four zero score and he is with Grandma
sir Maurice Ashley thanks Jen well
congratulations me evicted today got a
it seemed like a terrific struggle stuff
happening all over the place but in the
end you got the victory how do you feel
about the game well I feel that was
actually I was trying to play some salt
yesterday so I came to the game I just
trying to develop my pieces the way I
usually playing and then when he played
he four and I saw that I could open both
of my bishops and then we're gonna have
an open position it was fun so I decided
to play like that so sometimes the plan
has to go out the window because the way
you feel at the board
exactly right but then my poem plays
really well he opened the position and
he got contra playing and and I thought
that long time that I was better but I
couldn't find exact way and then I was
started thinking and thinking and
usually what happens when you think a
long time then you find the real bad
move which happened my case so after e3
I thought I was already worse and was
the matter of whether I should go for
minor inferior endgame after Queen takes
a three orchard oh let's just get to
that move here but III here right no but
instead of mission t5 so in this
position t5 could take only three and
then white is just bet him because he's
in gamers superior or you know mix it up
and try to sacrifice ekend pond for a
counter play and I decided to go for a
counter play because he did take the
pawn in fact he took my truck here this
was the critical moment a very big
moment in the game right and then I
thought that he had to play Queen e2
here because the idea isn't that if I
take 106 it takes on d5 oh yes which is
nice Intermezzo so I have to take on g2
here so it takes take this here in
kingship and kill you right so instead I
have to take on g2 and force the draw
Queen e2 there right mm-hmm
so Bishop takes g2
and if King takes two - then I take 106
Quin a six no I'm sorry and I forced the
drawer with the night a fortunate Wow
because we just point this out - right
it goes in the Queen the King has
nowhere to go from checks and the Queen
just harasses the King completely
alright and that was the drawer I
thought would help on the board now
there was another variation after rook a
eight that he could have tried to
consolidate with Bishop f1 you
definitely have compensation with rook
takes
yeah but the you know he used a very
passive and I was comfortable
disposition because my pieces are
centralized you know and they have more
space so I felt I could make a drawer
here easily so but after the bombs when
he ate of course White has just lost
right
beautiful finish he just missed the
tactic of III did he say what he missed
after the game well now you've started
brilliantly for no best thought you
could possibly have are you already
thinking about the $64,000 fisher-price
no that's really it's not possible it's
not even possible it's out of your ass I
think you're being modest there but for
Oh start and the great start to the
tournament congratulations on your win
and best of luck in the rest of the
games thank you back to you Jenna yes
well thank you to God and Maurice and
although God says it's impossible it's
certainly more possible than it was at
the start of the tournament right well I
love the way Maurice tarses and the
interviews we've got a gotta thank you
for joining us congratulations on your
victory today it seems like Groundhog
Day four days in a row
I mean God obviously is feeling
wonderful and it you know as the number
one seed when everything goes into your
favor sometimes it just continually
rains and falls well speaking of number
one seeds let's take a quick look at our
game here on the webcam between perfect
score irena crash verse angelina Belikov
sky and boy is she fighting and we'll
take a quick look at this while we get a
tattoo of Abraham Eon the Dragon Slayer
set up for her
with Maurice when we had left the game
we had saw that arena crippled black's
pawn structure Angelina bellows kiya was
under technical problems Bishop d2 Queen
d7 Bishop c3 aiming at this week pawn on
e5
we really liked arenas game at this
point three okay just preparing to play
maybe King g2 and keeping alright she
didn't want maybe work f3 and/or cafe
coming in at some point although I guess
II five would have happened yeah maybe
there was some way in which our black
could have done that after protecting
the e pawn so okay Bishop d6 King g2 was
played King came out from the corner
King h8 to g8 and this just looks
terrific for arena blacks pawns are
really weak h5 Wow okay
h4 Queen takes Oh big big decision there
okay D takes e4 recapturing taking this
isolated pawn from backward pawn on d3
and transforming it into a powerhouse
here on e4 arena's just simply playing
very very good technical chess here very
big positional advantage here for white
exactly I like what she's doing and now
it seems that she's just preparing to
retreat her bishop something like the
ship to d2 and going after this pawn on
c4 she has other ways of increasing her
advantage in my view perhaps even just
grabbing the open file with a move like
rook d1 and I like everything about
White's position here I must say indeed
but there's still some work to be done
but arena crush definitely sitting
pretty and perhaps you'll join got a
Kamsky in the 4-0 club wow I guess these
see the seating really does show it goes
to show that
the correct seating order has been made
thus far in the tournament as Angelina
and we see in the webcam arena always
has that kind of thorough at the board
except when she's in time trouble then
she really drills down at the same time
but not so focus that she gets burnout
so a really good attitude and it looks
like she's going to really put the
pressure on Angelina in this game and oh
but I
nipping at her heels we've got tel c5i
Angelina Angelina seems to have just
simply blundered hey Carrie pawn at this
moment let me just double check me and
this position which we had rook c2 well
there's a B a rook F to here
well there's she's attacking their work
enough to thank you oh that was that the
previous move so yes after Bishop takes
e5 black and returned the favor with
rook attacking the bishop sorry I was
thinking oh my gosh you just blundered
or you've gone with a game of tempo
there is some time pressure so things
could happen but now let's go to our
player in the Women's Championship who
is you know really giving arena I run
for our money so far in the beginning of
the tournament she has three and a half
out of four points talked to Barbara
haami on is with Grandmaster Ashley to
talk about her thrilling game thanks Jen
Tata congratulations first of all on you
win we were following this game we were
even making movie references how to
train a dragon was it out of tama dragon
did you suspect that a dragon was going
to happen in your game today
yeah so of course I threw you everything
and it was a good thing that I did now
were you surprised by any of her moves
who was the one to deviate first from
known theory well she's just so nice
move I haven't seen I mean at the board
when she played it I started doubting I
did I forget my preparation but then she
said that it was a move that she came up
with at home I guess and so I guess just
want to deviate it but I mean the
position is still really complicated but
I think I came up with something good
well yeah you win you win caveman
or as Jenna likes to say cavewoman honor
this game was extremely exciting it
doesn't look like you had just a
dominating position at some point though
she just she just came up with some
moves that didn't make any sense but
maybe 90 xg5 because I can't just play
Queen h2 whenever I want with a tempo
getting my queen on the rock on day 12
the Canadian right so I thought after a
4 before was the move so night see to
assert unless I can get to the H fell so
fast yeah I think 95 just kind of goes
against how do you feel about a game
like this I mean it's extremely sharp in
stream lis intense a lot of variations
calculate but in many ways it's a short
game and follows the theme of the dragon
that Fischer laid down a long time ago
just open up the H file in me do you
feel like you had to expend a lot of
energy to play this game or it just
seemed like you know it's just natural
I mean it's so complicated it's so easy
to over calculate something just to
listen it's something to make it really
easy mistake even at the end I was
planning on playing g6 instead of quit
h5 and then I said Crenshaw just made
some few moves you know like given tours
and it's so easy to sleep and not just
something easy or over complicate things
so I think it does take a lot of energy
you seem to save your best chest for the
US Women's Championship you're half a
point ahead now in the tournament you're
the temporary leader in this event how
are you feeling about your chances
moving forward well the last seven
championships have been won by either
arena or honor I mean we need a new name
and you face okay well we wish you the
best of luck in the rest of your games
congratulations on today back to you
genin yes all right and let's take a
look at arena crushing on Jelena belikov
sky his game alright but before we do
that and I'll definitely come back to it
and congratulations on that on taming
the dragon look at this crazy game
between Shibboleth and Alexander Oni
shook this was a game where black had
this massive
of number of palms on the queenside in
the center which maurice was pointing
out or just begging to come down the
board and it looked like Shibboleth was
basically lost the computer assessed his
position as being down to ponds and we
have we're seeing a dramatic turnaround
because the world's number the the
events number three player number three
seed alex on only shook at this point
three point four two two the good check
this one out
we get here here and the computer
program just went zero zero zero thanks
to this amazing will look a six blacks
queen going after this pawn on g6 and
you know show ball is going to see this
because this sets up for Queen h4 check
attacking the King as well as the rook
and the computer just says draw forget
about your brain we can show why that is
if if black tries to like to escape with
something like King F seven well your
favorite lots better to draw ventilate
much better to draw then to lose and
after Queen takes probably Bishop f8 is
required
oops pardon me and look at that twenty
four to two white so King h7 it's just
back and forth and then you got the
back-and-forth routine the repetition
that were so often seeing this perpetual
check it looks like mr. Murphy would
have failed the p55 check as well
probably let's see why why would I move
just so terrible
oops excuse me Bishop here check looks
like it just because you're coming
you're coming into f7 again right so for
example say King here alright
yeah and then okay go ahead and then
after now Queen f7 with the double
threat of Queen g8 and Queen takes
activate so too much power in that
diagonal so let's take a quick look at
the the crush game because it looks like
you only know belicoff's kya is getting
into some beat deep time pressure here
although the position is pretty
simplified so I think her position will
be more of a problem than her clock when
we left it it was rook ff2 here I made
the whoops jerk why not capture the pawn
on e5 that did in fact happen Bishop f4
closing off these the connection between
the two rooks and preparing to capture
this pawn on c4 arena looks like she's
in the driver's seat and cruising one
pawn up big advantage to arena computer
agrees and a big part of that that kind
of reminds me of the pawn the Larry
Christianson Jam down Brian throat yes I
think something similar is gonna happen
in this game now we have a a grandmaster
another grandmaster who's with Maurice
Ashley now getting ready to talk to us I
think for the first time in the
tournament as well yeah one of our most
popular grandmasters also a coach and
kind of a st. Louis local all right we
accept your is very good people so your
each woman with Maurice at I thanks then
thanks Jen with Grandmaster URI Schulman
a former champion at this event your
you've started off kind of tepid maybe
the best way to say it with four draws
what's going on I think I played
interest in games but somehow like maybe
didn't catch my wind yet so in round one
like I blundered in exchange and the
position was good enough to survive in
130 moves so it was okay and in this
round
it was interesting fight and it looks
like you know I had an advantage in the
end that I just didn't see the McKinsey
tool but yesterday you know like was
exchanged French what could I do
I mean we even try to play both of us
try to win them what is it what goes on
in a player's mind when you you feel
like you just stuck in the mud a little
bit you know what do you do to spice up
your play without of course going
overboard and end up blowing up I mean
yeah you should find your own motivation
yeah play chess I mean of course you can
start playing some gambits but I don't
know if it's time yet now today's game
this moment we've really highlighted
when I spotted this situation happening
the computer says that all you have to
do now is trade on d4 and then play 94
and you have a slight advantage instead
you came up with this amazing idea
sacrificing your queen which should have
led to a perpetual check as it turns out
oh did you feel really uncomfortable at
this moment that the forced is drawn I
mean I didn't see that like I was have
enough compensation after Ruby for CD
for 94 I just didn't feel like I have
more than enough like I mean there is
some risk but maybe you know maybe
position might be even but I didn't see
but so I felt it like I didn't have
enough in this game so well at this
moment he could have taken a draw but
instead he went even more with this move
and it turns out that now suddenly you
were winning even right you pointed this
out I'm asking you to move that this
variation 97 Ruka three and I only was
thinking about Queen e2 maybe which is
good enough maybe as well but after
Queen e2 there is some look after tomb
of King Queen e2 working in community
that's not what I was calculating and I
thought rook F 2 is playable but I don't
know obviously King takes runs into d3
and it's in this Bishop mm-hmm is also
giving checking on the long diagonal
right so backing up moment rook d4 CD
497 and rook f2 and you're saying the
move Kings you teach I didn't look at
this moment it looks very strong
yeah it's attacking the rook and the
rook seems like it has pretty much
nowhere to go
yeah I was only thinking to attack with
the Queen but because it looks like you
know
five might be a move but you always can
block with the night him I see that's
very paradoxical putting your king on
this long diagonal and your Knights
under attack I can see why he wouldn't
miss something like this I mean she
should have taken a drawing I yeah
maybe I should have tried my chance if I
had seen King g2 maybe I would have
played it well I can understand why so
the game ended in a draw now you're
still at 50% you have two points I've
gotta calm ski is really putting his
foot on the pedal right now he's at four
do you think about that now do you
wonder what you need no not at all I
mean I played up to my skill you know
not just trying to overtake out and
gotta I would say like you know in the
first three games at all worse positions
so you know so today came two horses
well really I haven't seen that yeah but
so you know he's just a good player so
that's another understatement that we've
got no we were the last time we heard he
was some guy well thanks so much one of
the more admirable grandmasters grand
master showman on drawing today
hopefully he can make it happen for
himself in the next few rounds genin
yeah thank you very interesting
sometimes when you go through these
spells where you draw a lot of games the
number of missed opportunities pile up
and you begin to have some self doubts I
think Yuri wasn't a hundred percent sure
of himself
today and that's a pity because he
really did have an opportunity and a
clear one and I think in a different set
of circumstances he would likely have
found the move kingi to we're always a
very interesting player and yeah it goes
to show it's always good to be confident
in chess yes go yeah let's take a look
at our youngsters game Sam seve on here
playing without an exchange but with so
coupons on the board do you think white
can make this happen yes yeah well it's
with all the pawns on one side there are
always there always defensive fortresses
that you've got to keep it
his white 7 here can we adequately
defend I don't know I just think that
look a seven we really need to get it
with the bishop and the King in order to
survive right could be coming to defy
very quickly
actly and if you if you start with I
guess you might want to start with
Bishop e6 there for sure but go back
just one step
so maybe white should start with Bishop
d5 to stop that Bishop e6 option what
you were just about to point out and go
for this F pawn with musai croquet seven
next looks like it should be winning for
white right because if we I mean well if
we try something like Bishop d6 and you
can come around the other way um and for
instance if Bishop d5 Bishop produced
six now you can go rook F aid this one
oh well I guess you I guess you couldn't
well I was thinking your for K 7 at
least you have at least you have a king
GA all right here you have 97 attacking
the rook and just although we're CAF 7
probably wins right yeah it looks pretty
good I don't think so looks pretty good
yeah this is an easier conversion right
just because we're seeing a lot of past
barns carrying the day this is another
one of them this looks very good for hor
gay and Sam Semyon is in trouble
probably escaped let's look for the
second youngest player in the tournament
who is celebrating his 15th birthday
house birthday boy do I you know I know
earlier we were protecting predicting
some potential time pressure because he
and AAB Ivanov had both used like
something like 70% of their time after
just says 16 moves we do have a result
it looks like a draw has been agreed as
you will recall this was a game I
actually did like Caiden's position that
was a little bit earlier we will just go
through it briefly and this is what took
place interesting
Alexandra Ivana sacrificed a pond for an
initiative and remember when I was
saying that that dark square Bishop was
White's problem piece he still had it he
still had it and it looks like Hayden
declined a repetition he was playing for
the win
whoa the computer just jumped out of its
seat after this move Knight age four
before that time computer assessed the
position is even or balance in Knight h4
gave a big opportunity and looks like a
missed opportunity for Alexander
Ivanovitch for Queen e1 check
immediately no biggie right so Knight
takes h4 Queen takes h4 takes on a three
we have Queen to be one check
Gina King in the rough precisely so this
is this take then you know it's again
it's just a goner or a goal or take on
p2 right pick your poison there exactly
so a3 was a big big missed opportunity
let's understand why so what's it so
what's the difference oh because we play
Queen e1 check immediately obviously we
no longer have that battery but um so
night h4 after Queen B for let's try to
understand this in human terms if we can
so after Queen before a3 is a threat
correct three so you must stop that
threat correct out to perhaps something
like Queen g4 so that maybe well Queen
g3 I was about to suggest bringing the
Queen back anticipating I would be able
to round up this fellow but not quite so
good after eight because after Queen G
what I was I'm sorry maybe I should just
move the king by the way I was thinking
Queen g4 a3 but you you're not required
to capture on
- and maybe a3 is just very unpleasant
because the Queen's and going to end up
in a very bad way is on a1 and it's
gonna be hard to attack that pawn
another time
exactly because the b2 pond is actually
blocking the way for other pieces to it
so that would be pretty miserable for
white so instead yet as you as you point
out something like king h2 one of the
ideas if we play a three now you can
just take it right right so a little bit
of a discovered attack slice a double
attack it's in chess usually it's a two
tactics kind of interacting with each
other right and here we're seeing that
white is just set up for this double
attack with Queen b1 check and Queen
takes C - and that's why you white has
to step out of the way
instead Cayden win for knight h4 and
then after Queen takes b5 he probably
breathed the sigh of relief as the
players ended up agreeing to a draw by
likely perpetual check well I think that
counts as a birthday present
hey Dad 15th birthday - dating Kate and
Rolf his his opponent did miss a winning
variation now we have a lot of results
coming in all right as we do usually at
this hour
Grand Master Robert Robson Grand Master
Robson beat mark Arnold Alexander and
Ivan up and and Katie drove was a draw
as we just saw and Ramirez won again
past and that was a fascinating struggle
oh ho bleep we'll hear from Alejandro
but right now we have ray raphson with
his first victory of the tournament much
waited I'm sure and he is with Maurice
Ashley thanks Jen here with Grandmaster
Ray Robson congratulations on your
victory today thank you
it's a long time coming it's four rounds
it's it's been tough on the collegiate
players it seems coming straight off of
finals and trying to jump into a US
Championship no matter how much you try
it seems like this the weight of these
these finals have been affecting you
guys yeah it's definitely interfered
with I guess our preparation and maybe
our we're more tired because of that so
hopefully we can start to come back
especially for me I hope that I can come
back well you played you play for the
team at Webster University I believe you
guys have something like eight grand
masters at the at the school is that
right
I think that's correct yes that's insane
a powerhouse collegiate school now you
also played against a fellow collegiate
player mark Arnold who's he's also
coming off finals from Indiana
University this game seemed to be a wild
game in the beginning he played g5 which
is kind of difficult in this opening but
we've seen the g5 virus going the Jeep
on virus going throughout the whole
tournament people are playing this Jeep
on on every board it seemed like but
this position seemed okay for black I
mean were you did you think that you had
a big edge any point in the game until
the very end this point I was definitely
not sure about the position is very
complicated I just my last move was
Bishop d2 so I was prepared to sacrifice
upon in the exchange if he had played
Knight takes D 3 and Queen III and I
take C 1 and so you're saying this
capture here which looks very natural
and this move and now Knight takes on c1
and then I thought the best was 95
uncovering an attack by this Bishop on
the Queen Queen c4 now he's attacking
your rook in the corner yes on decide
after play rook takes c1 it would take
solving that problem now he can he has
to play he takes d5 otherwise 97 and I
take his queen he takes back and
probably Knight a5 and although I'm down
material he has two rooks for a queen
and an extra pawn I do have an
initiative so I was not sure about this
position if I'm better or maybe it's
just unclear but he was down to about
two minutes also so I thought this would
still be a good position for me to play
so the time pressure factored in as well
especially with Knights and queens and
unusual distribution particularly his
King in the middle too understood well
this didn't happen in fact in this
moment he played this move Bishop b5
yeah I was not expecting that and I
think what I did was best not I just
play 95 anyway again uncovering attack
on his Queen he played Bishop takes d3
check that you don't mind King over and
then he took your pawn on e4 mm-hmm and
now maybe he was expecting originally
nice e7 check and then I
the rook but he has two pawns for the
exchange and he's relatively safe so I
think I found a better move I took the
bishop Ani sevens now his dark squares a
very weak without this and here he went
for your rook on f1 and then you play
this amazing move Knight to c8 did he
seem shocked when this move appeared on
the board mmm didn't seem shocked
although I don't think he had time to
probably had 30 seconds and so now I
think it's winning for me just I have
too many pieces in the attack and his
King's not safe in the middle so it
should be a winning attack indeed
there's Knight fork coming back here
attacking king and queen is a huge
threat and in this position he saved his
Queen and then Knight takes d 6 check
King D 7 and then the lady shows up and
it just looks pretty terrible right now
so the finish was rook fc8 Knight takes
CA rook takes and then Queen d4 check
any resign so satisfying victory at the
end your first victory of the tournament
you're standing at how many points now
is one and a half one and a half kind of
a bit distance from gotta calm ski at
four are you thinking at all about maybe
still winning this tournament or maybe
just playing your best well before
yesterday's game I was still thinking
about it
now I just want to just you know have a
decent performance and I just don't want
to lose any more games so just try to
come back well we wish you the best in
that effort and congratulations on your
win today thank you
Grandmaster Ray Robson with his first
victory back to you Jenna yes Wow I
appreciate that Grandmaster Robson was
the first one to give her a real answer
to her you can think the rest of the
tournament
no more losses I like that okay one game
at a time I know that feeling very well
that comes a time that you just want to
stop the bleeding in the pain and Ray
hit it right on the head
no more losses just let's have a good
performance in the games and head in the
tournament and it's it's yeah it's good
to get the monkey off your back you know
I think we're gonna see some good things
from Ray more more tournament results
yes we do have a Ramirez defeated hesse
and he's going to be with
shortly all right and a very big game
still between Anna's Adamski I know that
she lost the previous round to arena
huge huge huge years old as we spoke
about but today it looks like she's
bouncing back against Victoria nee with
a fine victory with the black pieces so
arena cannot afford to relax no
especially not we talked about that's
only half a point back also that's
that's big and she hasn't played part of
yet so of course it would be impossible
for her to win all her games and play
against somebody with just one draw
exactly my math skill is creeping in
here that'll be a really big game yes I
have an eye arena yes yes it will and we
do have a grandmaster
Alejandro Ramirez who played a beautiful
game today lots of interesting tactics
and we're gonna hear from him and
Maurice Ashley thanks Jen with the
Grandmaster Alejandro Ramirez you won
today congratulations oh thank you how'd
you feel about the game where you played
well I think I was ahead the entire game
I went into the game with quite a bit of
confidence I wanted revenge because I
lost yesterday against Conrad and
looking at it with the computer I was I
had a draw a safe at the end I was
almost miraculous and I didn't find it
so I really wanted to at least try to
push with white and I felt that I was
ahead the entire game so I was pretty
happy about that and the finish was it
the kind of pretty finish you wanted
yeah I think I've been a slight mistake
that I shouldn't have been getting into
time trouble when there was no reason to
because I almost already upped the
exchange so all I had to do was keep the
position simple not really allow him any
counter play and instead of that I
started to calculate unnecessary
variations luckily one of them did work
and it was this variation with Queen
1896
and well I mean I still had not just
enough time to calculate it so I was
happy about that now we've been blaming
poor play on the collegiate players on
the fact that he just had finals but you
just graduated from which college is a
University of Texas at Dallas yes so
what's what's your excuse for not
playing for having a bad game I guess
I'm a little bit out of form believe it
or
I have been playing as much I've been
very involved with chat space comm and
I've been doing some annotations for
them and a co-editor now so I've been a
little doing a little bit more of chess
journalism then playing and I think it's
reflecting on my game I wish I could
play a little bit more faster but
luckily I wasn't as Rusty as has for us
today yeah we we're in the chest
journalism circles know exactly what
you're talking about oh yeah as it would
definitely agree with me all right so
you're still sitting pretty though maybe
not as pretty as calm ski at four but
you do have two and a half points Oh
count ski one again Wow yeah he's
pulling off pretty amazing miracles
every game what do you feel about your
prospects moving forward well you know
going into the tournament I didn't
really come with any expectations
having plus one is pretty good I mean
I'm performing above my rating I'm
playing I think pretty good chess my
whites have been really good so far so I
just want to go into halftime with at
least positive score okay well
congratulations your victory today and
the best of luck in the rest of the
tournament well thank you Grandmaster
Alejandro Ramirez
so victory today moving on Jenni yes
master Ramirez looking sharp his shirt
matches your tie well there you go I
mean good taste
Bernie you bet well congratulations to
ollie Hondo as he gets back to his
winning ways big game he lost with
Conrad Holt that was the Banco gambit
and I couldn't understand you know you
just feel well nobody likes a loss but
an undeserved lost I mean he felt that
he had to draw all the way at the very
end that he missed okay but how do you
think Ivana feels after this game after
missing 83 you know it probably was
because of time pressure yes I mean I've
seen him in tournaments where he just
like starts thinking and move on and
he's a fantastically prepared player
right so it seems that it's almost like
this this adoration for chest kind of
like starting from zero every day
everything it's kind of romantic but it
also seems a bit absurd right right you
know you have all this preparation and
you start thinking and move on
right and we're talking like 20-30
minutes sometimes you have to be yes oh
yes oh yes you have to be practical
sometimes he loses that in his time
trouble he just he just I
it's almost addicted to the rush of
being under pressure yes and you know he
was raving about the fact that the 30
second increment I have and I was saying
how the 30 second increment improves the
quality of its games because it's kind
of like the time control is managing the
time for the player at peace Eisley so
you you can't get into those two second
situations and I do like the 30 second
increment because I think it creates a
fewer fewer in insane situations where
the arbiter has to just make a call
right you know our pieces are flying
right just like ugly things that can
happen at least some type of increment
even though it's not 30 seconds there
should be something no I like the
30-second increment I really do I think
it's very good for the players they're
more importantly very good for the
quality of the game yes although some of
us do like to see that like kind of a
shot and Freud I like seeing our I see a
person with like five seconds left
oh really fun to watch sometimes though
plenty of people lose on time even with
a 30-second argument no well maybe we'll
get more insight on how big-time
pressure Ivana was in because we do have
the birthday boy international master
cadent Rolf with Maurice Ashley thanks
Jen well first of all happy birthday
thanks all of 15 years old how does he
feel it was good a lot of chess in those
years
oh I started just at 14 can you imagine
I'm like an old man I can't even imagine
that so you had a game today against
Alexander Rana which those of us who
played and play played him over the
years know he always gets into time
pressure was the entire pressure again
today very very much so there was one
point he sat there for a long time and
okay there was a lot of time being spent
but I'm just like we're really early in
the game and you know you're giving me
this huge time advantage that could that
could cost you and it was really
surprised by that now you played a good
game but at some point you got this
position and it turns out that you made
a serious error here probably in his
time pressure which is which is
something people are famous for doing
you play the move Knight to h4 and it
turns out the computer goes nuts when
you do that because of this move a3 you
probably should take first I'm sorry yes
that's right let's back up one second
Knight takes Queen takes and now this
move a3 and it looks like you're in
trouble pawn takes is not possible
because of Queen check winning your rook
you did obviously didn't see that during
the game
no I act I saw it a few moves later but
I didn't see it here and then someone
was showing me while I kind of just
sitting around he's like you realized
you were like no I didn't yeah we were
both getting kind of low here so it was
stuff so that time pressure cost him
because if he had some time he probably
would have found this move yeah strong
Grandmaster like that I think we were
both getting minute minute and a half
ish here so it was the pressure was
starting to come well luck plays a big
role in these tournaments you I've heard
you did a music video this is kind of
exciting a chess player getting into
music videos I think we might have
footage of that video to show you
getting involved here we go I believe a
rock a rock band is it that's that's
doing this video you were part of I'm
not sure you call it rock it's more kind
of like the I mean they have two violins
and a piano so it kind of gets a
classical kind of sound it really was it
was kind of crazy
I the only reason I'm really in it is
because I'm a good chess player and they
wanted they the idea of chess for this
music sounded great and you know you
kind of see the music and the chess
really go well together and it's but for
me my personal favorite those moments
when you just hear the clock sound and
it just stops and then all sudden the
music gets back up and the chest starts
going and that for me is really exciting
really cool well we see Magnus Carlsen
doing
g-star commercials and being a
spokesperson you're doing music videos
it's great to see the young player is
really taking the mantle of chess to the
worldwide audience
so congratulations in your game today
and we wish you the best in the rest of
the tournament
he's a national masticating trough on a
pretty good game today one little hiccup
but you'll be fine
Jenna yes a little preview of it you can
find it on YouTube PLC trio of cave-ins
also got a Facebook page where he has a
lot of photos on it I think that's a
chess champion Kaden trough you can look
that up on Facebook we also just posted
it on the USDF website really a cool
video and nice to see some kind of
unique promotions of chess there I love
it I seriously I do new generation new
ideas welcome welcome welcome and again
the maturity of these players these
young youthful chess players to master
but a fifteen year old James Bond
exactly that's very cool
very very cool but again I mean we chess
grandmasters chess educators love to say
that chess has a positive benefit on
children helps developing young minds
the gymnasium of the mind and also sorts
of other superlatives I'm gonna just
change it and say chess helps you mature
that's it
you know just teaches maturity one of
the things I noticed growing up is if
you're a chess player you're more used
to it like kind of interacting with
people of different cultures and
different ages especially adults yes I
mean a lot of like 14 15 year olds like
except for their parents and their
teachers they don't have you know
conversations with people in their 20s
30s 40s 50s and clearly where they're
equals right now that's very very rare
that's true I always felt that chess was
my entree into the adult world as it
allowed me to sit at the table and talk
with people much older than me and
really enjoy their company so yeah the
maturity of Sam said beyond and Cayden
Wow just great I'm blown away yeah
that's pretty funny sometimes it's the
the kids that are the mature ones in
certain situations I remember in the
opening ceremony Sam Sam Yuans father
who's very animated
yeah you know started off fist pumping
when you saw that Canton you drew the
white color cuz that meant that Sam 7un
was most likely gonna get five whites in
the tournament I'm some young is just
sitting there like totally chill okay
okay well bring us up to date how are we
standing in two tournaments do we ask
well we mentioned earlier that Tata and
Irina is gonna be a big matchup in the
Women's Championship octave now playing
great with three and a half out of four
Irina looking poised to increase her
score to 4-0 just like how to camp ski
and those two are gonna play in the
penultimate round so round eight we're
gonna seat octave and Irina faceoff hot
tub with white so it's gonna be quite an
exciting game and that will undoubtedly
decide to win this title right there
that game is the the key game so
something to look forward to in the
Women's Championship without question we
do have this wild game still going on
between the two Alexes alex Shabalala
versus alex Oney shook when we went back
shocking to me really because I know
Chabal off is such a tactical player you
know when we got to this position
oops I apologize we wanted to go back
and say here this is where we saw that
nice little I gotta grab the okay
absolutely and the computer won't draw
you know just really that would have
been great but instead what we've seen
and it's a wild position white has won
blacks Queen as we can see here for a
rook and a bishop but that's not the
salient feature of the position the
salient feature is all of these black
pawns most critically this pawn on d2
and it's clear that black just he just
wants to Queen his pawns but at the same
time he has to avoid perpetual check
let's see how the game went
we get to this point jack-jack Chabal
off doing his best to try to make it as
difficult as possible for black to
advance his pawns we have this position
and it is white to play I think the
computer at least thinks that it's not
quite a lost cause that a big advantage
for like Queen c7 Czech Queen it's
probably remarkably enough the King is
probably just gonna go for a while
ooh minute they're not the bishop I'm
not going to lose the bishop you were
hoping for it easier exactly okay so
after work d7 queen c5 check again and
we'll see where should I go some reason
to go to d8 no I don't think so
let's just keep marching up the board
check make sense and this time I can
finally play rook d6 interfering with my
rule now of Queenie a check on e8 check
also okay now I think I can slide over
and I don't see another check for you at
this moment which means do you want
Queen is coming Reese alright so somehow
Ali's hand to her own Ashok here with
another immaterial in balance I think
we've had our fair share of imbalances
in this tournament it seems like there's
all sorts of unique ones you know
normally you don't see that that often
right and it's happening almost every
single round so I think that really by
the way is due to the players and the
way the Swiss system actually works
where the winners are constantly being
paired and those pairings you know you
need to win in a Swiss tournament you
have to have a high score so I think a
lot of the players understood that
coming into the game and they decided
that they were just going to play their
most risky all-out openings and defenses
that they need to to win as many games
as they possibly can and with God are
running away at 4-0
now the other players trailing behind
they have any chances of catching him
they are gonna have to play extremely
well now we have another question from a
Twitter follower about who gotta calm
ski is likely to play tomorrow and it
looks like based on this game it's
probably gonna be Alexander only shook
yes because it got a Larry Christensen
has three points but God has already
played him precisely and nobody else
will have three we have except except oh
no except maybe Benjamin Versailles Coby
answers if there's a decisive result
there exactly we haven't looked at that
game for a while according to our
instantaneous look the computer thinks
that game is pretty balanced but if
anybody has an advantage the computer is
giving it a smidgen of an edge
- Joel Benjamin who has the white pieces
against Barra Cobian and that dangerous
looking pawn but well blockaded by the
base of our g8 right so let's see how it
would go
that's an interesting move and not that
it turns out that maybe this night on c8
and night on e7 is actually not very
well placed the computer interestingly
enough likes the move Knight c8 and I
would definitely not call that a human
move if anything I would probably wanted
to play Knight f8 Knight f5 Parr and me
followed by king eise evan so i could
stop this pawn so for example in case of
here here we just see a quick variation
that I'm putting on the board white in
this line is emerging upon up and a very
big advantage so that was one move
Knight c8 - pre understand or can best
understand after the swap this capture
in this recapture this is where the
computer thinks that black should be
able to draw and b5 in another trade and
so on so probably he would play whom
well honestly assuming that he wins that
game again tomorrow who of course is our
number three seed and
anybody's going to be you got to think
that how have we have had that same
situation from a tournament standpoint I
sure would like to see almost forget the
white pieces
yes but I'm got a Kamsky it will likely
get his do color ever playing way right
so that that'll be oh that's really
tough though I mean playing Kamsky with
ye but can't see he's gonna be in kind
of a tricky situation because on one
hand you know we might wanna play
something more solid than usual because
he knows that you know he's just running
away with it at this point everyone on
Ashoka's is basically his top rival at
that point exactly so you might want to
play more solidly than usual but then
there's a counter-argument if he wins
this game the Fischer prize is within
his horizon right and I don't believe
him when he says he thinks it's
impossible I just don't believe him I
think it is in his mind that if he
manages to beat ownership with white
it's only four games and at least one of
those games is gonna be probably against
somebody who's not in that top tier
because of the oddity of whisperings
yeah I mean I well obviously to get a
perfect score you've got to start
perfectly well and foro is impressive
start but I'm kind of sharing God as
skepticism it's very very hard to pull
off nine in a row on the other hand in
terms of playing only shook you know at
a certain point you just stop playing
solid you start saying to yourself hey
wait a minute you know like you heard
Yuri Schulman and the other players hey
God is just getting lucky he's just a
lot of poor positions that he's pulling
out a win and if that's true well just
keep pressing your luck just go all the
way forward and so I'm thinking that
against on his hook should he play and
it looks like they will god I should
just go all out or not I agree you know
you might as well try and so you're
saying that you don't even think it's a
factor and not that like I mean
obviously God is just gonna play chess
these guys are true so-called play for a
draw but let's just say it's like a
difference in maybe an opening choice by
one that's hyper aggressive and one
that's like more normal you don't even
think that it's a factor
the Fischer prize at this point because
he just thinks it's impossible just
doesn't enter into his but if he be
gonna shock man it will start to or you
think you have to go 600 for it to start
becoming like you have to go seven oh
really
no $64,000 there's a lot of moolah I
think he's started thinking about it
with six points but but he will never
I'll tell you this he'll never admit
tomorrow you could be a toe in the last
round he's saying I'm taking a one game
at a time that we won't accept
speaking of Amore's Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley has something for us on your
point Jen you know of course I'm gonna
badger him every single round as much as
I can to get him to say that he really
wants to go nine and oh the thing though
that I think you should take into
account is first of all the tournament's
very early on it's only four points four
points that he has out of nine so it's a
long way to go but you also have people
who are chasing him who no longer have
to play him somewhat like Larry
Kristensen for example who we know is a
beast and will try to kill everybody
he's sitting in front of and is not
happy at all that he lost his game to
Kamsky he's won this tournament several
times before and he must be thinking
look I'm just gonna have to beat people
because I'm trying to win this
tournament so even though God it might
not be looking to go nine I know he's
gonna have to still rack up points he
can't start thinking or draw is gonna
get it done because people are still in
the hunt Jen and Jenna yes that is a
good point you do have to keep your eyes
on the prize which is the US
Championship title very prestigious oh
yes yes but we want to secure good
result and as Marissa saying Larry you
know at this point in his career to
another factor that enters into it is
you know like how many opportunity to do
you get to become US Champion and one of
the things like wily veterans like Larry
myself
Maurice yourself for that matter if you
weren't it's just doing commentating is
when you do get that opportunity to play
for the US Championship or even
try to clinch the title you seize it you
just put put everything else out of your
mind and and focus and go if Larry's in
contention going in the last two rounds
I wouldn't count him out of it not at
all he could he could pull off the
upsets and as Maurice says he's already
played I got it that's true yeah we
shall see and have a game it looks
pretty awful for samsa beyond here our
youngest participant in the US
Championship the youngest participant
ever 12 year old Sam seve on trying to
hold a position he's an exchange down
but they're all the pawns are on the
same side of the board the problem it
would be great for Sam he would play
Knight takes out five in a heartbeat if
it was his move and I suspect in that
case he could make a draw the problem
he's facing is this move rook e8 f8
going after this f7 pawn there's no way
for black to defend that pawn and then
after let's say this trade Knight takes
f5 rook takes f7 in case of this move
King g6 I think the simplest is just to
play rook to f8 and notice how this rook
controls the F file keeping blacks King
at bay from there I say it again another
central passer it's just looks looks
crushing for Jorge is a more husband and
it much is it is unfortunate this year
twelve-year-old falter it's also kind of
nice to see Jorge he's such an
incredible talent you know coming back
to the game after mostly playing blitz
and rapid and he's usually just so good
it blitz and rapid but I know that he
he's amazing a lot he's so good at like
one minute two minute three minutes
chess he's fantastic but he I think is
normally a kind of a time pressure
paddock but he seems to be handling his
clock very well in this tournament so
maybe you just solve that before the
tournament some psychology you know just
kind of woke up well he had those two
setbacks at the start of the tournament
and
as he said it well he's finding the best
way to lose I mean snatching defeat from
the jaws of victory in his game with
cheval off that was really really
painful
but you're right here's a here's a blitz
specialist of swords and here well of
course they're playing classical time
controls he's adjusting well and we'll
see again it is early it feels like so
much has happened in four rounds already
that a lot of action is already taking
place it's not even halfway in the
tournament and we got a lot of chess
ahead of us drama-filled indeed
how was Irina crushed going in closing
out that game against Angelina I thought
she was doing well let's go give it a
quick check see well she's managed to
keep her material advantage when we less
we around these parts a very solid extra
pawn in the arena's last move was Bishop
c3 a very nice move by the way just
cutting off the connection between
blacks two rooks that were bearing down
on the g3 pawn which aru going for the
g3 pawn rook III hmm I must confess
myself I would have been more tempted by
the immediate e5 rookie three Bishop e5
so Angelina probably calculated that her
best chance lies in this double rook
ending well for work anything I should
say and we're here well the first thing
is how about getting our King into play
and playing g4 and then if we can play
g4 and bring our King to g4 and f5 that
surely will lead to a win for white oh
yes with those two passed pawns I think
Irina's got this one in the bag and
that'll be yeah but it'll be a long
fight because Angelina's known for being
a big fighting player so she's not going
to resign until it's like really clear
and I don't mean that in a negative way
yes
working games you know if somebody slips
up too many times things can turn around
they're notoriously drawn rook endings
even when your pawn or even two for that
matter ahead the defender has great
opportunity so you're right Angelina's
not giving up for a long while and let
me again just for another interesting
game in the Women's Championship which
we haven't checked into is Camilla
behind Skye T against Elena cats and
there we've got another material
imbalance where we've got another
exchange where white has gotten the two
bishops and has also kind of imprisoned
some of lacks pieces I think you're
gonna like taking a look at this unusual
position so why eat with two bishops
that terrible Bishop on a a but glass
with an extra exchange but I see a big
problem and that big problem is h4 or
today is the day of unstoppable pawns
and that Bishop on e5 so well poised to
just dominate the position yes I mean
obviously for the moment the rook on
i-87 is stopping it from marching to h7
but our plan could even be to stick a
Bishop g7 in at an opportune moment
right well here I must say Camilla looks
like she's playing her best game of the
tournament because this is a beautiful
positional control game by white and
personally I just love the idea of
improving my King maybe just bringing
the King up to f4 the site before
deciding about whether I should push my
pawn to h5 I think Camilla is winning
this game hands down
oh this makes a grand positional
impression indeed it's a really
beautiful position here by Camilla
behind Skye T giving me the youngster a
real tough grind here a good lesson a
good lesson indeed sometimes it's nice
to have a dominating Bishop on e5 for an
exchange
especially with an age take a picture of
that patient so you've got a Alexander
Chapel of an ownership which seems to be
one of the most thrilling rounds of the
day it just it just looks fantastic
for black but let's check in and only
shook in his his King dashing technique
has he been able to avoid all this these
perpetual and when it becomes clear to
Shaba that he has the game will be over
right well when we left it that was
precisely what sure ball off was trying
to do was create a perpetual check and
Alex only shook was doing his best to
avoid the perpetual check I think we got
a line like this ourselves
yes very similar that we were going to
this and here we are and it's a
according to the computer only shook has
made tremendous progress as he's gone
from a one-and-a-half pawn advantage
basically doubling it to three pawn
advantage and the computer saying if you
go King g6 you just ran out of checks Oh
amazing
whoops you certainly do I apologize me
for right at least one more at least one
more several more now after King f6 and
I guess the idea is we if you give us
two more checks I guess the idea is we
just want to put our Bishop on e5 does
that make sense and allow and allow f4
and then just just Queen yeah and allow
Queen takes e5 check because now this f4
move has induced a weakness and on there
on the first on the second rank right so
now the Queen is taboo whereas before we
were looking at positions with the pawn
enough to here and we just you know
probably that's winning for black to but
you just didn't want to get into that a
team to dominant for black to go into
that two rooks first clean and game
right you prefer to kind of keep the
bishop yes so that's a nice line but
it's not that obvious
of course owners took some fantastic
players so he'll probably see it but I
think it's a little counterintuitive but
the plant it should be five allowing f4
especially when you have to analyze it
far in advance well we're looking at all
the different Queen Jack's computers
always tend to make things look easy
when you know and we've seen that in the
tournament that you know if you're
watching at home with you
and then like the computer the computer
sees so many things that humans don't
see and it doesn't make chess any less
fantastic it's just you know just a car
runs faster than a marathon runner right
well here the problem is after if you
don't play the move Bishop e5 you have a
little bit of problem getting out of the
perpetual check exactly so you have to
see it seriously that you think you're
confident that ownership will walk into
this variation oh yes there's probably
some other ways to tool that might be I
don't think there's any other way I did
before we were looking at like another
kind of King walk well the problem is is
that you get the you're repeating the
position in this particular case all
right but what about going back to da oh
yeah I just think I just think there's
so many different possible ways here and
the one with putting your ribbon 85
seems a little bit less human to me this
one seems more human all right
that's interesting I mean these days I
don't know what it means to be human
Queen Queen age for Bishop f6 now and
stops all the jacks right Queen h4 Jack
issue yes but okay after for example
look like queen g4 attacks your Bishop
defends d1 for the moment still a bit
messy lurking lurking mrs. Bishop f6
perhaps well here I can imagine for
example how Y could climb his way back
into the game
thanks to this H pawn keep in mind you
don't want to fall into a trick like
this where you play c4 prematurely and
leave Queen g8 takes b3
hey we got enough pawns we can jettison
one of them we don't make it hard for
our opponent as possible no we don't I
may give them any counter play but we do
have Grandmaster Ashley with an update
on a game we haven't seen in a while
Nora wits and Feingold thanks Jen
well as you said computers make fools of
us all and this game there was a
opportunity for Ben
I go the club resident to play a
superstar move that he missed but so
deep to analyze it it was incredible in
this position here it is White's turn to
move white saw this threat of this
Knight plunging into the d3 square
forking just about all of his pieces
look here Queen over here and another
rook over here so he said that's too
much of a threat so he played the move
Queen to e2 to deal with it however he
must have seen another move this move
Knight to e4 looks a little funky
because his Knights under attack but
actually his rook is attacking this
Queen and he's forking to pieces as well
and he must have calculated this - it
and this doesn't work but it turns out
if he had looked a little bit deeper and
this is a line I'm pretty sure he saw
this Queen sacrifice it looks amazing
for black and after rook takes rook
takes we check and he said if I take
this the guy's just gonna fork me and
you know I'm gonna lose my queen - but
if he had looked a little bit deeper in
this line he gets this rook at the end
and suddenly it's material equality but
only for the moment because this f7 pawn
is going to die he cannot be protected
and then maybe even these other pawns on
this side so White's gonna have a
decisive material advantage he didn't
play this got into trouble and now he's
actually in a lot of trouble looks like
he's losing his game right now genin yes
beautiful opportunity there classic
94 double at double attack and yeah
Marissa is right on the money right that
for certain Ben saw that but he just
like Murray said he probably calculated
that position up until the time that he
loses his Queen and said oh that's not
good for me
misjudging that once the knight does end
up on the d6 square well guess what
there's no defending the pawn on f7 so
missed opportunity by Ben fault Ben
Feingold here in round 4 costing him
dearly because I have it as Yaakov
stickers Noora wits as winning as is
that a confirmed result Jenn
only me what that is that a confirmed
result Yaakov win winning um I I think
it I think that is yeah yeah but we'll
find out soon and we also have a Ana's
at Husky here so let's take a quick look
at Irina crash as we're getting her set
up for him area I think we were just
looking at and it looked like technical
exercise here for Irina
she's March her pawn to a6 we left it
around these parts and we thought arena
really had things sewn up I was I
thought g4 was the simplest but arena
chose rook a8 King g6 and just pushing
her a pawn up the board now that was
gonna freeze blacks rook behind White's
a pawn see if I was played a six and we
have this situation hold on what just
happened
rook takes a six I believe that has been
played so was his arena planning to go
straight into a King and pawn endgame
something like this probably she can do
something like this and win maybe King G
you think she's came out this and you're
wrong you're like oh there are so many
other ways for her to play you know
maybe she can gobble on some pawns okay
you think there's a simpler win than
this so Angelina is captured on a six
but I've been trying to push the pawn
really forward and make it easy for
black to capture we can start with e six
yes and then maybe after work to a eight
something different here perhaps oK
we've we've got some moves on the board
know that the players right the players
to have caught up to us
okay okay right so now it does arena
have something more settle well we'll
find out very soon but let's now go to
an
Donsky who just won her game and now has
three points in the US Women's
Championship
she's with Grand Master Maurice Ashley
thanks Jen here with Anna zoton ski and
it congratulations in your victory today
thank you Morris were you winning all
the way through was it a straight
dominant performance or did you have to
overcome some real resistance
she played very solid line in Slav
defense exchange variation so it's very
difficult to win and she is a solid
chess player so it was very difficult I
had to find some moves and I took some
risk I think she could good she could
get advantage during the game did you
take this risk because you feel you need
to start winning all your games because
of what happened yesterday no I don't
know this is just how you can someone
who is a low-rated
than you you need to take some risk but
she's a very good chess player and I
know that she's not feeling well so
maybe in other situations she would be I
don't know talking about yesterday
your main rival that was a very
difficult game she played well you both
played well for quite some time in this
game I'm not sure I think it's like some
ideas if she would play instead of
Bishop g4 maybe 94 she was just so much
better well we don't have the position
in front of us but so you're saying that
you think that she could have played
better or you could have play better
gameplay better games than this one I
think yes and now that you have three
points or it looks like she might be
cruising to four maybe not you're sort
of not in control of the tournament
anymore it's really up to her if she if
she keeps winning all our games how do
you go into your mindset of these future
games I told you before the tournament
like my attitude to the tournament will
remind our our new listeners already
told before the tournament so it's I
will probably take like break from chess
so it's I think it's not it doesn't
really matter my performance here and
okay it's not a final I know many many
features players after losing the game
this okay I will stop play chess yeah
but I told you remember
for the tournament yes which is very
still playing some but not Victor omits
the reasons for this or your children
[Music]
not not emotionally ready to say like
all the reasons and yes likes family and
stuff I see well we hope things work out
and you don't quit chess because
fantastic player will take a break okay
well you still have a lot of room to go
in this tournament
anything could happen it's only four
rounds so we wish you the best in your
future games
I feel ya I feel you Maurice has been a
long day too much excitement thank you
Anna thank you very much for joining us
there were too much excitement here at
the same so it's chess club but yeah we
most of our games are wrapping up here
we were just looking at this crush
belikov sky a game in which ye six just
occurred and then we're k-8 and now
Irina is trying to find the best way to
go here and as we take a look at this
game we also have Yaakov nor Wits who is
getting set up for an interview yes and
uh for those of you who aren't watching
on Saturday we calling stickers because
he on the Sabbath can't write down
that's right because it's considered
work but he's permitted to use stickers
with chess notation on them to complete
you know you have to take chess notation
especially when there is a 30-second
increment that's what I'd use a
30-second increment that it's always
going to give you enough time to write
down a move now will it give you enough
time to place three stickers down I
don't know a blitz ticker competition I
think that would be perfect for Yaakov
Horowitz because he's known to be a
fantastic blitz player right especially
the bullet time control areas and maybe
he'll tell us a little bit more about
that he's
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley thanks saying
here with Yaakov Norwich after your
victory congratulations thank you very
much so your first u.s. championship
what does it been like I mean I remember
my first one is a completely novel
experience confusing playing all these
great players what's your experience
been I never know what's gonna happen a
win loss or draw I'm just trying to play
well and I was happy I got my first draw
now I know I can't get zipped and now I
could be W now I could just you know go
out and try to beat everybody but I was
happy to get my first draw and just get
in the paper very good attitude you are
known as a blitz specialist that's what
you like to do is play quick chess how
was it transition been playing against
these fine players in a slower time
control yeah I've been playing more
tournaments so I'm kind of becoming
hybrids I like to think of myself as a
future slow specialist deal we wish that
for you now in this position how did the
game go first of all before this moment
did you feel that things were under
control or would just just want control
but I wasn't sure if I'm playing for a
winner or a draw I wasn't sure if I had
went to break when to go for advantage
if to go for advantage you know when I
play I always have basically in my mind
my coach Roman jingeos really I know
he's watching the game well he tells me
he's be watching he was one of the top
10 players in the world I mean yeah and
I know he's watching and I know he has
soared on top of my head he's ready to
bash his computer when he it's all I
have to play the best move I kind of I
just have to try and play the best way
and we know Roman he's a burly guy he's
sure he doesn't he doesn't care he gives
it to me on the head
oh my god in Iceland I play I had a good
torment but I was drawing from 2600 feet
a guy's a new Roman game
this is ridiculous we cannot continue
like this and I knew I had to win the
next two and I won next - Wow well he
was he would have been very angry if you
hadn't found this next move you played a
really star move right now
when you play this move or what was was
it difficult to control yourself the
excitement of the moment must have been
thrilled to 40 yeah 40 a--the movie even
time controls that's a critical decision
at the time exact but it it was crazy it
was it was didn't we had about 30
seconds left each we play only on
increments last five moves it was it was
crazy I can't believe how well you're a
blitz specialist so what's the favor but
actually bed is a bit of a blitz
specialist himself oh yeah both of you I
wouldn't even have any doubts you're
going to finish this game
I kept composed I just relaxed and
pretended it was a blitz game I didn't
pretend it was a slow a oh it was a
tournament game or any I just pretend it
was a blitz game and 30 seconds left
okay for you 30 seconds you can make 13
laughs I I've had history of slow game
is spoken despite the fact that you're a
bliss pusher and now I played as if it
was a blitz game very good well that
that was a great moment for you you the
capture here and you were able to
capture on c1 and win an exchange and go
on to win okay rook c2 if Queen takes c1
now mercy to check first and pick
everything up Africa King back and then
this is check kicking off the knight
very nice the beautiful finish a
beautiful variation because it finished
differently so last thing everybody's
starting to call you stickers now
because we didn't know that on the
Sabbath you can't write your moves down
but you can but you someone came up with
the idea of using stickers to to record
the moves my other mentor why oh my
chest - is dr. Richard Lewis and he and
he had idea that I could use stickers
instead of writing you can use stickers
and that out I wasn't sure if I could
play the tournament because it's very
very strictly Sabbath and you know I
woke up two days later he's stickers
amazing you know those of us who teach
kids chess the hardest thing to do is to
get them to write down all their moves
but maybe this stickers idea you should
patent you could use it with our kids
yes
well good job congratulations on your
victory today and we wish you the best
in the rest thank you back to you Jenna
yes wow what a great victory bye yeah
Canora it's nice to see and I know must
be confusing for some of the viewers at
home when he says I tried to play this
like it was a blitz game right what are
you saying is this is the type of
combination that he would see in blitz
because he's so good but he sees these
quick combinations and blitz but with
the pressure or the tournament game
sometimes you actually reduce your blitz
level and play well it's nerves
I mean nerves in time trouble in
tournament games here obviously he's he
knows all the combinations in those
moments and sometimes you go gosh how
could I have not played that move I
would make it nine times out of ten and
blitz and sometimes you have to relieve
the pressure by just saying okay it's
not so serious but let's treat it as a
blitz game exactly like we're in the
skittles room at the world open and it's
yeah that's right I just had some fun
here but it was I was delighted to hear
about rum and gingi Havel a grandmaster
yeah gingy a long time dear friend of
mine is teaching Yakov and really
inspiring him we have something on our
demo
Maurice is mentioning that that Bishop
e5 f4 variation has appeared in the
in between the two Alexes what we look
why are you pulling that up let me take
a quick tweet by a Bronco 70 using the
hashtag us chess champs
he asked who this tournament has played
it the most number of times well we did
discuss this in the broadcast Broncos so
we can tell you're not taking all your
time off work to lots of this but we do
appreciate your question nonetheless and
the answer is Joel Benjamin Joel
Benjamin is playing for his 26th time
and Larry Christensen close behind
playing for his 25th time I I was aware
of Joel Joel has like this iron man who
played something like 20-plus
tournaments in a row that I didn't
realize that Larry had played so much
that's that's truly remarkable laughing
exactly
truly so the players did reach this when
we we got this position between
Shibboleth and oniy shook the third seed
Alex only shook did play this move
Bishop e5 and this is where we were
looking at that line with f4 that that
would have been allowed d1 so what
happened was rook d1 c6f for group d5
and the computer says these black pawns
just like the Saints are marching in
very nice and kind of similar to your
tie color as well and I heard we have a
speak from mr. rsync field and he
wonders where did you get that beautiful
tie well well Rex recognizing a gap in
my wardrobe rushed to fill it offered a
burgundy tie on loan which he made very
clear and I just want to say Rex this
doesn't mean we're dating
burgundy the new black and we also have
some interesting development in the
Savion game we really thought that was
in the bag for Hayes a more Hospital yes
indeed isn't it but it looks like a semi
on
later might be holding onto things I'm
how here oh my goodness he must have
laid a cunning trap when we have left it
remember when we left it in a position
like this and I said this move rook F H
should seal the deal well Sam came up
with this one how about that six then
came six Knight takes f5 this all looks
aged or interesting move okay king came
to g6 King h2 hmm well I am confused by
this many things a five you thought that
he was more likely he was just gonna
start pushing the pond immediately what
did you think here well no actually I
thought after half six he was going to
capture the problem yeah well sure I
mean you know win upon whenever you can
if you don't see me quite logical - he's
that pot looks super strong so how did
this happen so 9f5 so h4 is a little bit
bottling like that move doesn't seem to
make a lot of sense because it's now a
target true that and I assumed Jorge
thought that after something like rook
here followed by e7 he was just going to
wrap things up and win on the spot the
problem is as blacks King is really
close so after a move like rook e8 King
G 6 e 7 King F 7 and black survives
exactly so somewhere hora gate must have
thought that okay after h4 black has no
moves
well that's true I mean why can't we
just move our King in slowly and that's
the reason why Knight drop back to e7 I
know you're switching places here right
you're gonna be playing King f5 match
precisely so but even then we got to
have some chances cuz we're gonna play
rook f7 and snap off g7 if you go for
that that direction but let's see what
are they playing in the game rook e8
night
to d5 and again this night is really
being a pesky beast attacking the palm
perhaps from this side and always hoping
to be able to play King f7 when
necessary
oh how about that one night c7 very
nicely guarding the promotional
promotion square at the same time
attacking the pawn on e6 I think horror
game has really messed this this up
badly and the computer does agree that
black is very close to to creating a
fortress in this ending where these two
very healthy pawns g7 and h6 I would
assume I move like night II 6 and after
for example rook check came back
Black is just hoping that he could play
King g8 and Knight f8 and keep it all
together and Sam smashing the draw from
the jaws of defeat and certainly jorge's
the more has been here looks very
disappointed though hence evian just
looks like he just got a gift Christmas
gift okay rook h8 and [ __ ] gay looks
like he's in a little bit of time
trouble well looks like this one is very
likely to go into the draw zone now
let's take a look at our only show game
which is beautiful to watch even though
it looks like many roads are strong for
owner shook it's just such a pretty
constellation of pieces with those pawns
right really if the pawns that are
pretty space invaders right yeah so
let's take a look where are we at in
that game well when you left it remember
we left it after this move F ah
Chuvalo of desperately trying to get as
many chances as he can d5 okay
Queen drop back to g6 but now the bishop
could drop back blocking the check to
the king at the same time getting out of
pre from a fine
check on g8 and here we have it in this
moment well we're looking at Bishop e7
I'm sure now the king is really getting
nicely comforted perpetual czar going to
be very hard to find when you've got a
rook and Bishop that can block those
checks so I think only shook well on his
way to victory in this crucial game
because it will set up a matchup between
our number one seed in our number three
seed for tomorrow right and that can you
just march right to the center of the
board if you keep checking on so if you
play queen be a jack
show me the very easy to play something
like can you see vibe and then if well
then you have actually thing you have
Queen c7 check which is a night a little
annoying because you end up although I
mean it seems like all these variations
are winning because even here if we play
Kingdom d4 or something and Queen takes
a seven I mean probably probably still
winning maybe C to work takes D to check
but maybe the other way the b2 one
Knights you have no more checks well I
guess you do have some more tracks you
could play Queen B for Queen f6 Jack not
some calculation but the checks run out
fast and we've got some news from
Maurice Ashley on board number one no no
actually yeah we just got we just have a
some some facial expressions for more
irrational Union he's showing us so we
should take a look at this game between
arena crush and Angelina velop scoffs
kya it has simplified into a pawn hang
game and let's take a look at how this
happened when we left it we were in this
position arena went directly into this
King and pawn endgame she calculated the
win
so see for though this was the wind that
she had calculated and away she went and
showed us her excellent calculating
technique
here let's see we the this black King
needs to be in the square and it's not
so white can simply win the game by King
coming back well you do I have to worry
about the hmm I was trying to say though
if you play g5 yeah g4 King here this is
a cute one what you want to do is maybe
draw blacks King to the h3 square so you
can queen with check so for example
let's say we go here here here here
King h3 and now you Queen check that's
good by I think the reason your move
wasn't as good is because maybe there's
a g1 with check is that the reason let's
see sorry so when you play when you
played King d4 at first right these are
difference that
no I think the reason here is the King
could maybe come back even the square in
this case yes okay so the other move
kind of shoulder is the King precisely
so shoulders the King I like that yeah
block it stole her from Dover ascii who
probably took it from someone else stole
it from me no he did not
Clark is a little bit older than I asked
though yeah he stole it from somebody
very worthwhile
I'm sure but no doubt but a very very
important victory for arena and this
move King d5 would she has played King
d6 by the way this still looks like it
should laughs similar piece oh well
because the King also can't come in as
long as the King can't come in to the
defense
she should be winning and it looks like
we we have a result no are they still
playing or is the result in yes we do
have a result in this game so Irina
crash as 4-0 joining gata Kamsky and our
arbiter here Frank guadalupe setting the
Kings in Irina's favor so fantastic
round had a lot of fun as usual
saw the two frontrunners in the Women's
Championship and the championship
increased their leads and we have a we
want to mention to everybody watching
online that we have on-demand replay at
us chess champs comm / video including
the first hour in case you missed it and
that will be available this evening and
we're gonna be back tomorrow with a more
action there's gonna be a free day on
Wednesday but tomorrow Tuesday we are
gonna be back and I'm Jennifer Shahade
II with grandmasters Yasir Sara Juan and
Maurice Ashley from the st. Louis chess
club and we will see you tomorrow for
more US Championship accent thank you
for joining us
[Music]
[Music]
you